and really what we need to do is to be
having great sex that's what we need to
be doing but we're not so we're going
elsewhere you know we're looking at so I
like people will have a classic fingers
guys tends have a particular interest in
a particular area nice
every man has it go - right exactly it's
yours so yeah I'm gonna be quiet now
except do you want to know big booms
particularly okay you've got sour kind
of things and so I didn't have to grab
it know what's so insect like doggy
position is something that for you is
that's what it is
she's so reading me right now on top
where you can hold it as guy exactly but
often guys won't say that Oh girls won't
say yeah I mean I'm saying actually I
put it all out on the light really this
has been a very revealing week on the -
you can just say we actually did a
podcast called Britain's darkness taboos
at one point so this is sort of funny
because we were laughing about some of
the subjects on the shore because we
were like how was that a taboo we saw
yeah our joke was we were already
recording he's doing okay it is a silly
time it's not again we were saying on
this podcast it's not a taboo to murder
and rape your mum that's not true that's
a crime to do is you just parted in the
live that's a taboo murdering your
mother's not do you know doctor doctor
thing you've got one that is attractive
it's definitely a little bit too big you
ever played taboo there no it was a
great game you should plan learning
something new all the time yeah if I am
you can't say ladies and gentlemen yeah
we're not Russell relevance I've done it
as professional as he did he said tell
bees I am a psychologist you know go on
therapy you know lovely preamble
worrisome mechanic absolutely brilliant
and he sort of sits opposite you with
the mic on he's like oh yeah and the
thing is with you right so thanks for
coming you're the third lady we've had
on the podcast so you know one of the
special select few another man it's
mainly a large show as you know I think
it's mainly been populated by guys
because that's where the interest has
been on the channel yeah but the more
women that we interact with the more we
find your actually alright yeah we're
actually just alright yeah yeah that
you'll find that a lot of women the more
lavish than the man that you'll meet if
we're gonna look at gender stereotypes
in the way that we attribute those
characteristics definitely and also
women talk a lot more about really
interesting material and things that
guys would probably quite especially
with each other though like men when
when men are sitting alone together I
think we talked about like football so
that women will go into the glorious 50
me and him have never I've never asked
him about what sex is like with his
girlfriend was never never you have to
yeah
I'm a bit more to share other than here
I think that sherry is so important
genuinely I literally am one of those
people where there is no subject that I
won't talk about I'm really happy to
talk about everything I like to think I
have a no shame filter yeah do you not
think though that's that's that part of
your job and your status
like you've sort of earned that right to
be that way do you know what I think it
is if I'm really really honest I think
that when you look at yourself as a
person you have options in your life to
either live
the way that I feel I live which is with
this degree of acceptance I'm imperfect
I make mistakes
my views not always correct but that
actually that's me
and it's not that I won't learn or
relearn or recalibrate some of my ideas
it's just that for the most part I just
think we're all human like we're all
animals walking around in jackets and
stuff
if that isn't crazy you know someone
lesser sort of hidden animals yeah well
you know we are kind of all that singing
these roles and there's something about
normalizing just how crazy is to be here
and be in this room and talk about these
things though why not have everything
but the self acceptance thing is the
hardest thing to get new from most
especially the people watching this show
who are like young people because
everyone's all on this like journey of
I'm one day I'm gonna be that perfect
person we never get there and eventually
I think some if you're lucky you just
accept like actually it's alright just
it should be Who I am
yeah it really is surprising to me that
I was kind of looking at social media
the other day cuz obviously a lot of my
job involves working with people around
things like body image and I was
interested to see that snapchat and
Instagram are like the two major players
for young people and I just started to
think about what that meant and it's
like actually if you think about those
they're just image not really about
conversation they're about my story I'm
taking a picture covering my mouth or
yeah Instagram is a bigger I like
Instagram it's fun if you do it in the
right way but when you look at other
people's I'm sitting there and you're
just not living that life at all
especially some because I know what
youtubers roughly I'm working and some
youtubers who out then like bolas are
actually living on pot noodles and it's
like what just put out what you're
really living like I have so much more
respect exactly and the other thing that
you were saying just then about young
people is that they've got that kind of
manifestation of who am i what am i
doing what do I need to be where am I
going and we all uh start those
questions when we were young cause we
did but what I can't get my head around
is why I adults don't just tell them so
I've got to Lance and my two sons are my
little masterpieces genuinely I look at
them and I think I have no idea how I've
done it yeah because they are miles
better than I deserve and I mean that
wholeheartedly
my mom used to say to me I wish on you a
child exactly the same as you and that
was not in a positive respect you know
she just
wanting me to help the hell I gave her
my children ah my lonely brilliant and
they're not perfect of course but I have
from day one told them the truth I've
told them that the kids who were in the
popular group even if you're in the
popular group they're all worried about
whether they're in the popular group and
more worried that maybe there won't be
in the popular group even if they are in
the popular group and the kids who are
the most popular are thinking I'm a
popular and nobody ever feels like they
actually belong at that point they're
all worrying and actually the thing is
that we need to do is we need to kind of
get people to start seeing what you were
just talking about that all Center City
actually no one knows what they're doing
their entire life we just survived it in
the best way possible unsafe to do it
joyfully learn stuff on the way but
never consider yourself an expert and
when people use the word expert for me
there's always a bit of a brain that's
like right you know how could I possibly
be an expert on people people are just
so dynamic you know put me in a
different culture I haven't a clue I
don't know what it's like to be living
in in a city in Africa what the cultural
standards are there I'm not an expert
with people I have honed my skills with
certain individuals in Western society
but to some degree until we have those
conversations with kids they're always
going to be doing what you're saying
watching these kind of things and trying
to look for the little finishes of hope
that tell them they're okay just being
who they are I think it shows a little
bit as well we were saying this before
we started sort of the podcast before us
when some people have a piss before
podcast we just thought so I just go
straight when when stuff is like
naturalized or is sort of everyone
accepts it as I can unspoken truth yeah
I think that's quite difficult thing to
breach and that's changing all the time
and I think certain people have really
learned to exploit that like so
politicians learn to exploit that
unspoken truth side that no one will
ever challenge certain social norms and
those tell me a little bit more about
that though um are you doing the site
really interesting no I'm just really
interested in that point I think it's
like what we were saying it's like a
bubble isn't it you sort of live in that
bubble you don't necessarily realize
until you leave that that there is that
that the way that things are aren't
necessarily fixed in the way that you
feel they are and they can feel quite
fixed in that moment a lot of people I
think could just feel quite trapped by
especially you find it in school I think
because that's such a bubble yeah but
you are it feels like there's that
social hierarchy instructor yeah on
YouTube there's that structure like
Logan Paul all those guys they're there
Jacque guys you've got the geeky guys
you've got funny because you came up
with one word which was what worried
when you were describing what kids go
through and I was editing a video last
night and the world Strongest Man was on
this short and he said his lot of his
depression and where all of his energy
comes from is the worry how does a child
of an even an alpha alpha male was
worrying about enough up in me life or
you know when we parents die what's
gonna like all of these worries that we
all have and I think that that is like
the source of where it all stems from is
when were young yeah when we're at
children I think that we're born into a
world where everybody around us seems to
know more cause for children but often
because we're unaware of how to
communicate our needs because again with
children and we're learning all these
new experiences going to school because
remember that's one of the big things to
me in Western society and everybody's
got their own perspective on this but
personally I look at children preschool
and this is not to do down the education
system like teachers worked really hard
in the UK but I think the system was
broken so I would take a child who was
maybe four years old before school and
you can test them in lots of ways but
usually they're quite divergent so
they're good at thinking critically
they're good at thinking about how to do
things physically the creative and
imaginary in that way but then you get
them to like eight years old and what's
happened is the system has taught them
the biggest myth of life which is that
you're either a success or a failure
that these parameters that they measure
so are you good at maths English science
well that has no bearing at all on
intelligence that will not make you a
successful here in birra
one successful one what will is your
belief in that method so instead of
accumulating young people's skills by
noticing what makes them individual and
unique we tether them to these ideas of
what intelligence is imagine being a kid
so from my experience of working and
having the privilege of working with
very socially economically deprived
young people and running projects for
those and your neck of the woods you'll
know exactly what I mean
when you're working with them you trying
to unravel all this language they've
been taught you know that they couldn't
read they couldn't write and they
couldn't indeed but they had been
neglected they've been born into the
excuse me wrong families you know with
the wrong parents who weren't very nice
to them that had poor diets very little
education they've been brought in to
crime all of these things and it begins
with you are this and I am that a
separation you are clever you are a
failure your succeeds your fail and the
young raveling of nice something that
takes literally a lifetime to get over
for those individuals I mean you go into
prisons you know nobody's talking about
the fact that probably 70% of the men in
prison have been sexually abused because
we don't want to tell that story do we
we don't want you to feel sorry for
people who are in prison but actually
you know that's really where society has
gone wrong it's funny to say that
because when I was 10 years old my mom
was told by my teacher I was destined
for prison and r10 should rip this off
completely like I mean he's a total
write-off and like to see what I've gone
and achieved I think his face issue was
wrong for now anyway I mean you know I
meet Logan Paul's like kids are getting
written off massively especially the
further north you go they do really yeah
because I think a lot of people think
London's that everything's paved with
gold if you go the wid thing is
especially in London neighborhoods next
door to incredibly affluent
neighborhoods but if you go to Greenwich
you can then go down to Blackheath or
other areas like that and it's not
there's not nearly the money but now
kids are all just an intelligent
although yeah it's also the teaching
that all those
inherent or like that you were born with
those things yeah I think that must be
really frustrated that's really
frustrating is a an adult when you look
back and you think you're told those
things if that sticks yeah and you can't
change that I think that's what
frustrates me when people they paint
traits as if you yeah is that right and
that whole leopard can't change his
spots but every call that they can or
they just learn how to treat their spot
yeah that's right ice pops but he just
it's and it's how you treat success and
yeah that's a good little piece is not
is is less about you know if you're a
failure then that's bad if you're a
success then that's good your failures
can also be good and your success can
also be bad because it can go you learn
I watched a really good story show last
night about Greek myths about myths and
from all over the world and there was
something about and we studied this in
degree about common narratives around
the world and how you can pretty much
pick out a common narrative from
east/west everywhere especially the hero
narrative of like got off at home you
leave home you have a challenge or you
have something you need to overcome you
learn and then you face your final thing
and I think that can be quite damaging
because everyone feels like they have to
go through that to get to the what they
see is the end yeah what you were saying
at the beginning about young people kind
of watching this and worrying where are
they going what are they doing that's
probably one of the things that every
human being could do to learn to stop
thinking and feeling because it's his
idea that there's no time this is idea
that there is a right way in a wrong way
and the reality of life is being content
is what matters and some people can be
content being brain surgeons some people
can be content staying at home and
looking after children it really doesn't
matter as long as you've got that
contentment and when you look at
happiness money does make a difference
because it makes it more simple you know
and you can't say to somebody with that
anymore nil it won't make happy what we
can say is if you've got a decently
standard of living and by that I mean
you can eat you warm you're safe
the stresses are removed then even if
you've not got loads of cash your
happiness level wouldn't be the same as
somebody who's a lottery winner because
you can't alter that that's about your
attitude what changes and what manifests
itself is when you start accepting that
actually as a human being you're good
enough it
meaning you can't learn to change and
transition and grow but that it has to
begin with that idea that I'm okay
fundamentally I'm okay no my history
hasn't defined me my future hasn't
happened but there's something about me
that I know inherently is okay from that
I don't exactly what you mean because I
feel like we were having to talk about
this recently and he said were you ever
in a point in school where you were like
I'm really happy with who I am right now
and I went Mia I said last six months
the first time I felt that and I'm like
I was 29 you know I mean so it's that
though isn't it but what you're
describing am literally like yep
completely feel but it's taken me most
one lately name suddenly life to get it
up yes you do a lot of like one-on-ones
I do I still do quite a lot of work yeah
it was quite interesting and I I went to
have CBT okay depression problem no not
the nationís forum just like like a
number of different little things
towards I'm yeah but when we broke it
down to me it seemed really really
simple it was just like when you just
break that thought process and you'll
just stop doing those things and it was
really interesting to hear someone just
say that because very rarely do people
say well if you just stop that thought
process that you go down you'll just
stop acting that way and it was really
and I got it like what actually walked
out it was like oh that makes sense
yeah I felt like what I've done you know
you fixed me facility quite just that
you know when people come through your
doors know that as their our most common
reason why people come to see you out of
all of the reasons and in my traditional
work which isn't private then people
would come with very high-level trauma
because my area is working primarily
with young people for example you've
been quite heavily sexually exploited
here just socially abused but on the
private level where people come to me
most of the adults will come because
they're searching for something it's a
sense of not knowing what's wrong all
the time but feeling that something
isn't quite right
and need to motivate change but without
knowing precursor to that what needs to
change
so usually reactionary feeling like you
know my marriage is ended or I've got
like basis type of thing well I mean I
mean I always like to think of Musa
think the wakening is I just think like
mid life's an epiphany car it is because
everything changes you know you spend
your life as a young person and this is
something I tried to teach my boys all
the time because my lads the kids who
obviously like gaming they like going
online they like watching videos like
this that's what they enjoy doing
because that's part of their childhood
that's culturally become the norm but I
try to enforce in them that
understanding their like childhoods like
fleeting you don't on a reflection basis
and nostalgia basis think well I'm gonna
look back when I'm 40 and go wow I
really enjoyed all those hours that I'm
a PlayStation it just won't happen
you'll think the memories that we make
on holiday are the memories that you
played when you make indents so I'm
trying to teach them that but bringing
back to your point I suppose that one of
the things that we do is we walk towards
life for a long time it's firsts you
know from having sex for the first time
going to a party for the first time
having your baby for the first time in
all these first you get some midlife and
it's the reconciliation that this is
coming to a close that our firsts are
over and our new endings are beginning
losing our parents were losing our
friends you know those coming for most
people for me anyway it was all about
one day I'm gonna be this person like
and you build everything up as and when
I hit 30 which I recently did I was like
130 I'm gonna be this guy and you know I
am not so when I was 14 and I had this
vision of what I was gonna be when I was
30 I am nothing like that person and I'm
glad to say I'm way better yeah but but
I had me is this like clean-cut like
perfect life nothing Bad's ever gonna
happen to me my life's been absolutely
car wreck but because I've dealt with it
and come out the other say I've been
looking but I think so many people get
to that point of 30 or 40 or whatever
age they've got built up in the head and
then they're like ah [__] ya know I'm
supposed to be this person I've built up
and I'm not that person
yeah that's the Western myth the Western
myth is is a blueprint you know you've
got a blueprint and it goes
you go to school you go to college maybe
go to university if you look here you
meet somebody you get job and then buy
you plan you've plants them what you've
got your pension your debt
you know I feel like me you haven't got
a pension I'm just gonna freestyling
I don't even care I might forget it who
cares about the pension I might be dead
but that is so damaging because it
suggests as the linearity to life you
know an ABC and what you just described
is what so many people who were
successful
maybe Grandda you know you got a pension
you gotta get a good trade if you're not
gonna trade you're gonna be a waster
I've literally made up as I went along
the whole thing yeah I think that's a
it's dangerous to advise people to do
that in a way because your your products
I think this is it brilliant about being
imparting to people the advice that they
are their best selling feature you know
if you can hone your skills and whenever
people come and say to me and I have it
all the time and it's kind of creates
this like grief and because I can see
exactly what needs to change but it
takes a lot of courage so if I ask
somebody what do you wanna do or be
they'll often either shrink a little bit
and tell me so somebody said to me
yesterday and it's a courageous she was
a reporter we were just doing an
interview and I just said so hey you
know what's your long-term plan she's
interning at the moment is she went
really bad and she went well I'd really
like to feel like the host of question
time and I said what is it about that
for healing but you've got that makes
you feel like it's embarrassing to say
it just feel like a pipe dream I see in
that load it's because I know if I say
for example someone like when I was a
kid so one of our friends once said he
wanted he wanted to be manager of much
estimated win the Champions League I
think I'll let you use guess who that
may be if you watch the kickoff I burst
out love them but when you have pipe
dreams like that people do think they
are ridiculous sometimes they happen
because you can't have success in that
vision and those dreams that you have
are there the purpose so when young
people and I used to work with a lot of
young people who were quite damaged you
know and have been quite broken down by
society and
than what they wanted to be and just
getting into even have a vision was was
he north you know but realistically if
you actually say to yourself this is
what I want and then works Wars it just
step by step by step the likelihood is
you will get where you want to be you
will get to achieve that vision okay you
might not be Prime Minister if that's
your vision but you'll probably end up
you know in a ministerial position or
working for local Parliament you can get
that journey going but it comes at you
realizing that it's you who makes a
difference
look agency is a big part of success
agency says you happen to life life
doesn't happen to you I remember when I
was younger feeling like everything was
reactionary for me you know I reacted
you know I made really stupid decisions
and reacted to those stupid decisions
and at some point along the way I was
like this just doesn't work one it's
broken because I'm following somebody
else's blueprint that by the way hasn't
worked for a long time
that's why society as it is right now
that's why we've got such a massive
class divide that's why we've got kids
on the streets and poverty and
homelessness that's why they're going to
be clearing the streets for the Royal
Wedding cuz homeless people you know
let's get rid of those they're bringing
society down you know this awful awful
situation in society that we've created
because actually we're all living lives
in the capitalist context where we buy
more to spend more so carry on buy more
so that we can keep spending more so
that we can earn more to pay for a
bigger house and a bigger car and we
know it has absolutely no bearing on
happiness and what it does it
desensitizes ourselves to all the people
though who really need help and stops us
being the compassionate humans that we
need to be and I said this before and
I'll say it again and I don't care how
stupid it sounds I always say that I
want to do as little harm in my life and
people are like what you mean you know
you can go run beat people up so you
just try to prevent yourself from doing
it it's not that I know literally every
day is a struggle see everyone who looks
at me cockeyed I just want to cry oh but
yes so it's you know it's that whole
thing about knowing your impact you know
when I do my therapy is all about kind
of minimizing the impact that my life in
this planet has on the world how do I
make it a better experience so that I
don't harm because humans harm all the
time you know we walk past people in the
street because we just think the begging
and they're gonna go and live in their
you know house before before outside and
we want to see that because then that
excuses us from action and that's
probably for me the hardest thing these
days about living in this Western world
because it's a world where it's so easy
to ignore need and to almost make the
people who have those needs seem
different or dehumanized or not willing
really to see the great gratitude within
it you know to actually say that they're
not they don't really don't really need
it because just gonna spend on alcohol
that kind of stuff that's part of
individualization and society yeah of
course because it's quite um likely it's
weird we don't look at the system and
sort of go systems that's changed
radically you they look at the homeless
problem it's problematic about people
don't seem to address that which is
quite unusual yeah and I guess that is
also partly down to the power structure
what you've got the power you don't want
to step away from that I think
megalomania of power but I guess it's
also if that system got you into power
so say you are Theresa May or whoever
and it's not me having to go home late
the government it will be different it
would be massively different if it was a
Labour government mental health would be
better but yeah in the first place if
that systems got to there then to some
extent she wants to keep it that there
was a story of her recent clogs from a
guy it was on unfiltered on Joe yeah
really great podcast yeah and it was
about a guy who went to Russia and a
synth and basically invested when the
Berlin Wall fell and made a ton of money
oh yes lost all that money and then made
a lot of money from basically revealing
the people who
defrauded the country of money then
almost lost all that money again because
Putin turns and turned against it yeah
and now he's had a law passed in the
States and in Canada the the people who
illegally got that money
can't get into the states they'll have
all their assets frozen and they're
taken away
he's trying at that law passed in the UK
but the Conservatives won't part you
know because no no because so many the
Conservative Party are funded by Russian
billionaires are only got yeah exactly
and so they can't they literally can't
do that because it would cut the funding
off to the Conservative Party yeah
that's a fun system is like really ah
but you know it's that thing isn't it
now that the whole of this system is
that this they're not actually
politicians anymore the rubberiness
traitors aren't my administrators for
things like the Rothschilds they're you
know they're there to serve a purpose to
make rich people richer and the irony is
that when people start talking about
people who want to have a better better
government you constantly get this
ridiculous rhetoric that for example
korben korben the rhetoric around
corporate it's just it's like liberal
fool who's gonna go and give all these
poor people money and none of them are
ever gonna work in like it's so default
it's such a ridiculous idea the idea of
creating environments for people where
they can feed the kids and they can
actually have a life where they don't
feel you know like society's let them
down there so they can start to build
that sense of privilege and attainment
and actually when you see it in places
like in Scandinavia there's places where
I'm they're giving a universal kind of
credit to people it's about 600 pounds a
month it doesn't matter who you are or
how much you when you get it and instead
of this in the Tory world where they
think we'll that's it then the whole
communities of people refusing to work
with that 600 pounds you know it's not
working that way what's happening is
those people are getting 600 pounds and
they go in got it for work as well I'm
gonna have you know 1500 pounds a month
and that means my kids are gonna be able
to go on holiday and then the people who
are wealthy and I given it they have
nothing to complain about because
they're getting it as well so this idea
of giving money to people who need it
somehow
disabling them and confirming that they
remain in that situation it's not
but that's the way we're taught I hear
constantly and I mean I try not to go on
Facebook because I don't know there's
such a divide now is yeah constantly
there are people posting these things
about you know how dare people who have
less want more and there was this stupid
thing that's gonna be really stupid for
me to say this actually on your podcast
but it honestly it kind of made sense to
me at the time it's called the Fredo
continuum have you seen it
they're like freddo's in late 1980 like
5 pay yeah we're like 30 P now so
basically for the average person to be
able to afford to Frederick they need to
be paid 17 pounds 50 an hour now people
were going mental how all the photos you
want how dare you pay some you 17 past
video is a joke just throws it so that
that below it is the turn the phone off
yeah never seen against you though I
thought it was off yeah but the anger
that people have about this person
particularly was saying you know
cleaners don't deserve that money the
only educated people deserve that money
right and that view exists so weird
clearance alright bowlegs honestly that
give them as much as I can get thank you
yeah I'm Cindy who does post trauma with
people in hotels because apparently
about once a month in every hotel
they'll be a suicide yeah really yeah so
that cleaners are the first people who
find them obviously I'll get on the
train obviously a lot coming up and down
the country yeah that drive us obviously
people deliberately jump in front of the
train and the drivers basically feel
like they feel terrible obviously
they're in the wheel at the time but
when someone does that there's nothing
you can do because it's too late at that
second and they have to take like weeks
off and have surrender so I think after
two they just retire you don't May
because it happened so they just don't
let you do it again but suicide in
generally I get that when I'm in London
quite a lot that you'll know when you're
traveling it's not irregular or not
yes so it's quite you know the train
stopped and there was one a while ago
where everything was was gone and people
were so hungry and you kind of like that
sense of inconvenience somebody has
killed themselves an inconvenience me
and that is do you know what we were
talking about a min ago that is almost
that extreme of disassociation not
community you know oh this person is
dared to kill himself ruining my day and
kind of thinking the ripple effects of
that death and you've no idea what that
person was in pain about you know people
don't kill themselves because they're a
bit sad on that subject have you ever
dealt with someone who you've been
having meetings with and then they've
gone yeah how was that deal with are you
my first experience actually was I was
22 so I wasn't even qualified and I'd
started working for pupil liaison
officer back in the good old days where
you just got thrown in without CRB
checks then you could just kind of work
for people it was a great great way to
start but and I had this client used to
come and see me she was probably the
most serious and as far as the mental
health requirements but this is a long
time ago you know and she tracked me if
you think now it is you wouldn't have
been anywhere in the era at that it
should have been I mean don't get me
wrong it didn't work but early I got on
very well with her but there was this
real is I've never had it since if I'm
really honest with you 17 times she
tried to kill herself and this is by the
age of 16
so she was somebody who had this
intolerable pain of living this real
real like Annie it wasn't that she had
terrible life she the parents but there
was just something I don't know whether
it was in her genetics I don't know
whether it was his destruction motor
than her but she just did not want to be
here and she threw herself off the
motorway bridge and I can remember
feeling really sad and also really
relieved because when you've worked with
somebody who is so able to express their
sadness and she was one of those
individuals who I suppose is quite
poetic alright very often creative
people so you were relief or hurt or not
be in pain
relieved as well no we were terribly
upset that she chosen not to continue
but it was also very present that her
pain was so so painful that we hadn't
figured out how to soothe it and I don't
think our system is very good a lot of
the time it's soothing I have this
vision one day you know when I'm in the
euromillions because obviously that's a
mood Ford yeah at least 150 million it's
going to need but I have ladies vision
and I've talked by it with my kind of
colleagues for many years that people
need a safe place to go and heal but we
don't really provide that and that's
game not to be disrespectful so the
clinical psychologists out there and the
psychiatry something because believe me
the NHS is absolutely broken by the
amount of people in mental health crises
and if you imagine being a clinical
psychologist for example the majority of
clients that you will be seeing in
patients you'll be seeing will be at the
extreme end of trauma you know really
really big because in order for you to
get for them to get to you it has to be
that bad they will be postin I would
imagine well this is the perception of
it is pawned off with drugs for a long
time before anyone gets to us it's just
we just don't have the resources the
government have ruined it you know the
NHS is being absolutely crippled and
because of that practitioners are
exhausted as well and they don't take on
as many as as required and you don't get
early intervention some do in London
it's better than where I live where you
live will be the same as the island you
know it's not really any good but even
when you do if you speak to
practitioners practitioners want to make
people feel safe and they want to offer
compassion but you know you've got a
limited amount of time and the
environment isn't that conducive you put
somebody on a secure ward it doesn't
feel safe it doesn't feel like home it
doesn't feel like a place of healing so
I've got this vision that what we really
need is a place where people can just go
and allow themselves to heal with good
nutrition exercise safe place to sleep
you know I think sleeping is really
important when you're in mental crisis
where drugs are optional but there's
also an option to kind of explore you
know different treatments that are more
I suppose really
or for some people because the medical
system is effective it really is you
know if you get something with really
severe depression and they go on
antidepressant you know often they will
feel lifted to a position where they can
start working with you and that can also
help them emotionally so it does have
impact personally though I think that if
you're in mental health crisis in the
Western world we want to medicalize you
and make you be okay in our society
because we don't really like dealing
with mental illness instead of accepting
mental illness and say this is part look
this is part of being human
you said something so pertinent you said
about the fact that that person people
who like kind of talking about worried
about somebody dying in a parent's dying
not having you know all these things
that are true they're real but we kind
of sanitize stuff you know my best
friend died in March like she's my best
friend since I was seven but you should
be with just best mates and one of the
things that I experienced during that
you know apart from being with her at
home throughout the process of her dying
was at the end you know you wring the
undertaker and they kind of say when do
you want us to pick him up you know
after the person's come out to say yes
that person's dead and I just didn't
wanted to go I didn't want to leave her
I didn't want to take her away so I made
them come I agreed with her partner that
they would come the following afternoon
at 2 o'clock we were just with her but
when they came and they put her in the
back and they carried arouse like isn't
that just crazy I think we'll move I
mean I've been around a dead body but
yeah and the attachment to the body yes
it's very hard to let go of that also
when you're looking at a dead body
you're sort of it really rocks you to
your core a bit of like I know that I'm
almost waiting for the eyes to Albany
yeah so yeah yeah you know yeah it
accepted that whatever we are whether
you believe in spirit or an energy or
just generally we're just going nothing
yeah it really fell to me like the
spirit had gone or what whatever that
person Mars is now not there and that is
the shell I still love that
I still had cuddles and hugs off that
shelling and what that shall be okay and
I'm attached to it I mean exactly
oh I mean that thing that you've just
said about and again everybody has their
own kind of spiritual beliefs and like
I'm a massive fan of Brian Cox he just
laughed me out of the room talking about
spirituality but personally certainly
when Pam died you know being with her
and watching the difference between life
and death it's like palpable it's
tangible it's not just because they
stopped breathing it's there's a
physical change the body just doesn't
look alive in a different form almost
like it's not it's not them but it is
them and the way that we kind of caught
the body off and I've completely told my
family now if I die you know when any of
those are aware I am staying at home I'm
staying at home like you know put some
ice on my abdomen I'll be fine you know
don't bloody and bomb me thank you very
much you're not sucking my brain tumor
nose I don't want any of that stuff I
want to be around people who love me and
who I love and spirituality wise yeah
the other thing that I think I've
experienced since I've had close losses
but Pam's like she's like she's my
sister you know and you know I miss her
and I'm pissed off that she died on me
actually if I'm honest I'll be happy
words but um when when she died I kind
of really started to explore love and as
a person who kind of is quite you know
empirically based or not I like research
and I like to kind of have facts
presented and I think there's always
questions about stuff you know I want to
as people I like a bit of logic know I
can tell you seem to come across as
someone who can can close off when you
have to sure because you have to give
people right advice and if you're too
emotionally invested you might not give
the best advice and also you don't want
to take your work home with you every
day and you're dealing with people that
are really law so there has to be some
sort of cutoff but when you lose your
best friend you come on so now you
exploring it in a different way totally
and there's been a few times in the life
workers as a practitioner that's
happened when I lost her
and what really struck me was love and
the fact that I started to think about
when people have got ideas of afterlife
or not having it you know whatever your
bag is if personally I believe that
there's something amazing about being
alive it's as simple as I just find it
mind-blowing I don't have to question
anything apart from the fact that I feel
this something greater I don't know what
that is I don't need to define it I just
don't feel afraid of death because I
kind of feel that there's a new chapter
whatever that is right I don't think
it's gonna be this defined idea of head
of heaven I think there's just something
like I said I feel it personally it's
just personally but when she died I
started to explore like look like why
would we love Sunday who's that hmm it
makes no practical sense does it because
if you think about death surely as an
animal it's far more survival orientated
to just dismiss it death right gone
ignored forget emotionally connecting
yourself to a death would almost seem
like a redundant process because it
upsets you it makes you sad you know it
makes you feel lost and then I started
to think but actually what if that whole
experience of love I kind of started to
see it as like an invisible thread like
the grief that I feel like the joy of
loss is knowing that you've really loved
you know and you've really really had
that connection and that that love
offers that thread so that connection
between here and wherever they are and I
kind of like to imagine that at the end
of my life when I take that last breath
those threads will lead me to wherever
they are wherever they are in the
universe whatever that is and it's
really helped me to kind of deal with my
grief you know I'm very open about my
grief and I'll miss her forever she was
amazing my philosophy is that when
someone who dies who you love I think
that the love that you had together is
what gets you through that death yeah
are really good because otherwise yeah
because you have to come to a point
where the sadness calms down a bit and
you think would what would they want you
know what they want me to hit the
self-destruct button in it some sort of
tribute to how much I love them
that want you to go off and be nothing
eventually so you have to come to a
point of oh yeah you've got to get on
with life and I'm the blessing of grief
is that it comes because of the
relationship that you had and you can't
have love without loss it is hand in
hand that's exactly at the the yin and
the yang and when I work on murder shows
and when I talk to people who are
victims of these kind of crimes no
individuals have been horribly abused
you do see kind of two particular
extremes which are the ones who create
legacy as you're talking about where
even the death of a child who's been
horribly murdered they take that and
they take the feeling of loss and they
project it into something constructive
and consolidate it in a way that moves
them forward and means that that child
or person they've lost creates legacy so
they're always there they're always
present with you know the shows I have
like parks dedicated to the castle
exactly and then there's the other side
which as you said this is the
self-destruct side well yeah I did watch
one show where I think the the mother
went on to become an activist and the
DAR just dragged himself to death yeah
Sarah Payne I think it was her that in
the dirt he died a long time before
honey yeah he did and that's very common
that people will well another thing is
when you see in the interviews right
after the death when they were outside
the call you see in the strength and the
mother and you could see the dad was
very weak yeah and you can see it didn't
take a jet I'll bet you there would have
been people at that time because
obviously I was too young who were
watching these interviews sat at home
there was an old lady sitting you can
see which one of them is going to be
whole other one up here oh it's gonna go
mental facility is this a really
interesting thing isn't it because you
kind of look at the research on
resilience and and confidence actually
and you can actually see to some degree
a DNA trace you know genetic trace it
there's like almost a confident gene
it's just a theory but they kind of a
quite built around the personality true
like a confidence but that does not mean
that you can't develop great confidence
or resilience anything to learn it
that's it cuz so
I really really struggle with shyness
when I was a kid I mean like I had the
worst coping strategy for shyness I used
to put my skirt my yeah no seriously I
used to put my skirt oh it's the worst
strategy what does I think Kim is like a
five-year-old Wilder's I just cover my
head and I make everything no Isis a
girl in the street with her underwear on
you know bizarre but that was my coping
strategy I like to hide and I kind of
got to I was really sensitive as well
like people would say something and I
feel like ruminating on it for like a
week you know even it's a very young
child I was very very hyper anxious and
I've got to high school and that
continued and I didn't necessarily have
a very good experience am i right and
thinking that the way you ended up be
becoming a psychologist have you were in
therapy right well yeah be lost it's
supposed to go yeah so yeah what
happened was I just stopped going to
school I just really hate stunned it I
just couldn't get my head around any of
it you know I went from being like a
quite a small village mom and dad you
know very average in a working-class and
then I went to a private school because
I want a place like for place and I just
couldn't get my head around it you know
I heard the word ski I thought that was
a yogurt and it turned out was the sport
I heard the word divorce I didn't know
what divorce was it was like suddenly
the world seemed a civ and I got to like
13 and I was so tired of being told that
I wasn't as good as the other students
and you know all of those kind of
messages that yeah in the end I just
didn't want to go so my teacher who is
brilliant actually
one teacher who just was my savior as
she will always be my Savior because she
kind of saw something about me that I
took with me she's power of good
teachers mind-blowing and my mom hatched
this plan that I'd go to a psychology
department I was since it's like IHS in
the psychologist and told I was
completely saying didn't have any
disorders but they wanted to see me
because they wanted to see whether they
could work on my hyper anxiety and all
of those things and I did that for two
years learned nothing just learn nothing
apart from how to fill you know an hour
session to your sounds like quite a long
time was
really really boring I know it's not
really sort of a window on how long you
should have therapy for but surely
there's like some people have it there
like 20 years yeah but I mean and I
don't well it's spring clean and style
through know people have likes deeps
like therapy psychoanalysis like forever
sometimes like lots of hours now isn't
ours I guess that's one way of coping
with it or if you have the money that's
the thing you have to happen I know
you're definitely not but that's not
necessary
I mean my mom's actually a counselor
which you know I'm like what your
therapist oh sure she'll be the same as
me and we've had chats about how you
know someone's ready to leave
you're the exit strategy yeah how that
works yeah and sort of whether you give
them like some people develop our own
counselor or sort of their own you give
them strategies and all these kind of
things two years is quite a long time
sit there are not developed strategies
so what was that down to it was down to
the fact that a lot of adults don't know
how to speak to young people and also
you need a young person to trust you so
at the end of every session for 15
minutes you tell me what we spoke about
yeah no disrespect to how it was it's
probably how it was done in those days
but if you actually asked me know how
was I want to start and how was I at the
end it was a lot worse at the end and
what saved me what really really really
saved me was going to uni I got a place
to do women's studies actually
originally when sis started and found
such a women's yeah really I didn't it
was like about history culture all of
that that whole that whole kind of thing
I went there and started doing cyclo use
an elective and then just went mental
into loads of extra courses and it so I
could do it I do you got a great yeah
yeah but what I loved about it was no
one knew me I was like this and that's
one of the things about the information
I love reinvention I think that anybody
out there who thinks that their life is
this and that's how it's gonna be
you can like completely transform
yourself by especially when you leave
the area I do
University was a real part I think I was
really waiting to go to lunch you're
having a lot of people have that when
they first came to this guy really
wanted to go I just wanted I didn't want
to be in a small town
yeah well be possible to avoid yeah
lolly will attend so yeah they trip yeah
my dad drove me I think yeah there's
like if you can free yourself from
whatever it yeah yeah all those
preconceptions and stuff like that there
is healthier I think if you stay in the
same tone your whole life I did it is
healthy you just get out for a while
have a year somewhere else or whatever
yeah I would agree with you although I
do also see even though I love Newcastle
I also think there's a real problem in
our society for people who do just want
to stay in one place and their
castigated for wanting to I find that
really problematic that some people do
just want to stay in a town make a
business there stay there and I think
that's fine plus it I think people have
a go at those some people for not a
spider that's small times that you know
it varies to be the very highest that
whole bacon yeah I think that he's quite
I'm just saying like just a few months
over a year
when you're learning who you are like
for me I did a lot of traveling in the
doing the job I did before YouTube and
then now coming to London I know I've
changed for the better through all those
experiences so oh yeah because the thing
about life is that you're constantly
looking at people holding mirrors to you
but sometimes the reflections that are
holding are completely incorrect so
particularly if you've grown up in a
certain place the mirrors that have been
held towards you may be completely
deformed and when you leave and go
somewhere else and kind of meet new
people in your new circumstances the
reflections are often far better because
you've not been held back to the images
that you were one of the things about
uni that really kind of upsets me
nowadays is I just feel it's becoming so
inaccessible and the truth is that a lot
of young people that I work with you
know you'd get maybe one out of 25 kids
if I was lucky who goes to uni none of
them will go now they won't go because
debt would scare them
and they would not feel it was
accessible to them it's not that it's
not the same kind of debt no this goes
every step no and if you want to put in
an environment of poverty the idea of
leaving with 60 K when you can't even
imagine you more might be on 15 K a
factory yeah that's a massive massive
risk to take and also it says something
really loud I think it says you're not
invited to a lot of people because you
cannot say in the country that we live
in there is equal in any way shape or
form for young people in fact I was
listening to am Toph who's just one that
still able to get me out of here I'm
sure she's a dead nice person she seems
they're positive and lovely I'm not
going to criticize her no but I think
she seems like a decent human being born
she comes from a world that I'm night
magic and one of the things she was
saying she want one of those date things
it was a bit of a like anybody you know
if I've got a few minutes Mike I might
go through some nice videos online a few
minutes to get myself feeling in a good
mood as she was there and it came up
with his dating celebrities dating and
she's had an argument with the guy the
guy opposite with her was a staunch ran
your labor she was saying how can you
even say that look I have not been given
anything and I honestly just wanted to
vomit because Nia Wong sweetheart the
way I'm stuff yeah thank you yeah end of
story
name stuff and you clothes that you're
wearing my kids couldn't afford in five
years you know and realistically to
suggest that this Natori mentality that
anybody can make it in bread it's
absolute bollocks well that's actually
another thing when you're going on about
university what people are nor who be in
the Union actually frustrated because I
like you know I've worked hard I've got
a first semi degree and I still got a
job I can't get a great job at all
children I mean I thought I know someone
who's got a first in the degree woman
and like I thought like that you'd be on
a hundred grand a year with stuff like
that no no it's just like MIT like yeah
the whole thing is Welling to meet you
you guys work in media and ball yes we
do do yeah Newcastle idea
so you've broken the mold because we've
all done the mid-may that's for sure
in London though you know
right if you want to get into the media
a lot of time you have to do an intern
how are you going to do an intern if
you're from Middlesbrough and you can
prove working-class family how you can
fund it but if you've got a dad who
works in the industry or in trade or in
banking and or a corporate lawyer then
bang gone you're gonna get in how is
that an equal society and it really pays
me off when people who like anybody can
do it
no become anybody can't do it I think
anyone could do it
but they doesn't mean you can that's the
problem is and they paint it the wrong
ways because if you have all the hookups
that you've just subscribed you can walk
into a job with me I had a fly yes in
order to get where I'm in that's it
that's exactly so even though you say
you could imagine the amount of doors
you have to walk and that's exactly my
point I think that's the that's the
problem is that I'm talking more about
the conservative mentality so many
people triggered in the comments love
years years old remember your support oh
yeah oh he's down down on most people
but it is that is reflective of the
Conservative Party is not a negative I'm
just describing what the Conservative
Party say on their manifesto which is
like you know we Pete everyone's got a
chance bla bla bla private they do the
privatize everything
it's basically an americanized but there
will be some people listening who just
to put the other side across who will
probably sit there and say well life
isn't fair [__] deal with it the
problem is I think also there is a bit
of a denial that a lot of things are
actually just inherently unfair in life
sure but we don't have to have a society
that represents that cuz fortunately we
are in a situation where it doesn't need
to be that way
greed if you look at it untouchable in
India of course life's really unfair and
there is no hell of a long way to go
before that kind of thing would ever get
resolved right but in the UK it wouldn't
take a lot it doesn't take a massive
shift to make everybody have an okay
standard of living because actually what
the conservative mentality is and I
don't have anyone months absolutely a
Tory Tory till she dies it's as simple
as that yeah always we argue back all
the time she's absolutely touts movies
and she's seen a different Britain so I
get that herb
section is different because she's
experienced a different britain but the
thing about the tour mentality a lot of
the time is if it's mine it's mine I've
earned it
but you have a privilege of being way
well I say to everybody right I was born
to the right parents
I got literally applauded if across the
road no matter how [__] I was doing
simple as that run over there still I
know I know that they reminded me of my
possibilities not my limitations when
everything was really a bit not a great
parent like you have to do that you have
to tell your kids dream why you're not I
mean don't put a ceiling on what they
can do well look what you're doing now I
mean who knew you know when you got
fought in your kid you knew you knew you
wanted to be successful you didn't know
what that picture of success was but you
wanted to do it and be it and be a
doctor at the time if you are I think
I'd like what I went through yesterday
will help I'm going to change the world
in search you know you've done this and
the thing about YouTube is low and I
often get asked a comment on the
negative of online world and then
they'll ask you because unfortunately as
a system we give so many bad examples
for the other website and then me and
him are like a bee in the sea with a
bucket right here like try to do a bit
like online world has changed the world
it changes the way that we communicate
it makes everything open you know you
can go online now and years ago you
could feel so isolated whereas you can
go online now and meet a thousand people
who reflect your situation and you're
suddenly not on your own and things like
YouTube and communicating with the
masses that's such a privilege and power
all in the same moment and as much as to
some people that's like what a career
you were youtuber actually it's massive
because one it's become democratic like
the YouTube demographic has made
everything possible for people whether
you are from Newcastle or Middlesbrough
Manchester or the middle of nowhere
can I cover out that with
more democratic not a hundred percent
Democrats it's not wonderful because now
they've got loads of marketers behind
rich so it kind of was plus about four
and no TV no more aware of it they yeah
let's get these guys the markets have
gotten through it and that's what ruins
it some degree but then they'll find a
new way that's the other thing I always
think that and when you create those
obstacles people just get even more
clever
they're like Harkins almost yeah
everyone's on site black cryptocurrency
now aren't they as well that's the next
big thing even money's gonna get
challenged these people are going down
the cryptocurrency view instead of
having banks and the banks are all
really scared and a little bit I'm like
I've just does it fitted me every day
whatever you down I'm like Oh
bitcoins really like worth it's why is
it you know who's ever seen a Bitcoin
right actually we heard I think you saw
a Bitcoin a mystery other day we had an
investor did you what did they say well
he's only just getting in he was the guy
whom behind you porn and faith taxi and
I he's he's invested a lot of money in
that and cuz he's he's addicted they
would get richer rich guy but what a
game the thing that blows their mind
though is that as much as it just rich
people just get really rich it'll just
go like here's a million powers and then
they'll go up ten times and we'll get
out like what nine million pounds more
but actually what it says to me is there
is a real change in the system like
people are starting to say thanks you
know they've let us down there's a lot
of negativity associated with them we
can do our own way so the internet and
the cyber world has both on a positive
and negative level changed the face of
our society I mean I just think we've
been born into a time where I've got to
see life without the internet you know I
know that my life would've been so
different if I'd Google at school could
got a really good memory
oh yeah probably do really well in
things but back in the day it was like
you went to the library
changing without people and families now
based on meeting people off the other
end they would have never have met
mind-blowing and also communication I
watch my kids and they communicate so
much better than I did
kid like there are my headset chatons
like 15 of the mates you know it's quite
close proximity mates and they were all
chatting and they feel like they've got
this social life all the time and it's
not just some people could see the
negatives and too much of its isolation
I get it I get it but at the same time I
think wow I would have been mind blown
when I was a kid but I've seen it you
know I've been the kid you used to have
to walk to my mates house knock on she
wouldn't be able to come out till after
a tea so I'd sit on the wall and that an
hour lay and then we go wandering now
for now I hope who we might bump into
any of the opposite sex for example that
was our life all the way yeah but you
know that's the deal isn't it at the end
of the day I've seen that change and I
don't think there's ever going to be a
more prolific change in society as we've
seen not in humanity no look at him it's
like well until the sex box come obvious
like I see it I'm looking for bring on
the search box i think i'm fiying yeah
you'll exhaust just by snowsuit
I think she'll run out of charge sorry
you'll run out of charge before you get
tired yeah not true cuz you said you
didn't discuss your sex life but I'm
saying yeah you're [__] sex until they
just do this anymore
stop stop for lubrication device so it
won't be funny at the time
so you analysed murderers as part of
your job and and more people who are
watching probably recognize you from
crime investigation and all that
I mean I love the show I'm absolutely
addicted and when you caught in your
lake tana and this is the point where he
thought he was untouchable and I'm like
yeah you tell everyone general I mean
what is it like to try and get inside
the mind of a murderer well I mean I
obviously work victims in my area but
what I'm thinking about what motivates
people to murder obviously is subjective
because every murder is slightly
different to the other but there are
some traits that you can just read in
those humans like particularly the ones
that we cover on Britain's darkest
taboos they tend to be very premeditated
malicious killers so there's real intent
and even from the younger people we've
only covered a few cases where for
example young people have been
intoxicated on cannabis and might be
having a psychotic episode you know
that's mental health which is slightly
different it's very different actually
but the murder is that we and well it's
very very very often you will not get
diminished responsibility for that very
often it was a couple of cases that
really stuck out in my main work with
the younger people when you mentioned
that there was one lad who was playing
games against another guy and then the
guy came round and killed oh my god
right bad no Louis Danes Louis days
literally lives days he is serial killer
in the making
Louis days now what's really interesting
about Louis Danes
is that from the story oh yeah and he
actually killed someone it was all too
we've been playing games against this
smaller younger blood and he went round
to his house and murdered him well she
what what happened to us Brett formed
this relationship with Louis Danes Louis
was older he fabricated this life he'd
come into some money
he'd had quite disruptive life to be
honest Louis but he'd come into some
money they think and he had this flat
and he started to talk to this lad Breck
who's amazing really good family his mom
was an amazing mom her lover she became
as well she's incredible she would leave
the door open so she was aware that
there could be predators online so she
would listen she was aware that was
getting his relationship with Louis and
she started to be concerned because it
felt like he was starting to dominate
and control his life a little bit
because Brett was excited he got an
older friend and he was being sold you
know all these things we're gonna happen
who's gonna give him a job who's gonna
help me until the IT world
Brett was completely convinced of it his
mom managed to try and kind of ease him
away and then Louis died being horrible
about her so trying to convince Brett
that she was wrong he went away on like
an exchange Breck spent a few days
abroad came back
told his mom he was gonna go spend the
night with a friend he went to Louis
Danes and Louis Danes tortured and
murdered him in the most brutal brutal
of ways and probably the most chilling
part of that when you talk about you
know a killer is the premeditated extent
of the murder and then the cool
calculated phone call to the emergency
services oh yeah his phone call he was
just stone cold it was like you have
just be in the shops and he kept saying
that's all you need to just let me talk
now I need to just talk because what I'm
going to tell you like we just did woody
would control the conversation he said
to her I am going to tell you in York
and Alyssa
don't interrupt me when you say what the
kind of cases that make me go cold
yeah he's it because I don't care what
people say don't care what he's actually
attempted from to write to the mother
from it is that a blogger leak managed
to get access to the Internet he said
blog or basically suggested that this
was all you know fabrication because of
course a true narcissist believes the
world exists for them so when you're
working with somebody who is very very
dangerous and psychopathic with those
kind of traits they see you and you you
just collateral you know you can be your
extras in the movie that is their life
that's it
how did you start to address that though
because that must be quite um like
because you're dealing with somebody's
mentally ill there yes that's so they're
not mental no because you never sane
they're saying but they're nice but they
have narcissistic tendencies understand
folks it'll be like me because I'm like
say how they're not into it because of
the things that we've done our mentor
what there's something wrong with there
there something wrong with the way
brains look so when you look at kind of
and again there's some research on it
all of the lots of research on it and it
pairs what you believe but when you look
at like the amygdala in the brain the
kind of immediacy zone you know when you
wanna have sex that's the zone that gets
you want to eat that's a more altruistic
sif you have more altruistic tendencies
you will have a bigger amygdala if you
have psychopathic tendencies you'll
turnt up a smaller one so we do see as
you're noting there that there is some
physical but it would not be impairment
it would not be impairment now you do
get in the case of Fred West for example
in the horrible murders that he carried
out he was organically impaired each
other severe head injury on two
occasions you can see some limits
sometimes with severe head injuries and
that kind of behavior organic impairment
when it comes down to something like
Danes when it comes down to a real
psychopath what defines them is they
know what they're doing and they don't
feel any conscience for it so what
changes isn't necessarily their mental
well-being because people are mentally
unwell so for example mentally ill would
mean that he did it because he thought
he was a ghost that he was like and then
he stops like whatever nice that's meant
limas so that would be like a psychotic
episode that makes you think aliens are
here and you go mental on it right
that's the way you go that's just not
how a psychopathic killer some
psychopaths can have mental illness with
it yeah but you know a true cold
calculating and if you you know this is
my theory and again this is not steeped
in evidence some kids don't go off and
think that this is real this is just my
theory of it I look back through
evolution and if you imagine that human
beings evolved at a certain rate and you
know until we got a fire and dog through
pretty much middle right we got eaten
and we got killed by things and you know
in sand we could for a gym we could kind
of survive from scratch right we've got
a fire we got dogs the dogs ate all the
scraps stopped infection the firemen
that we would scare away animals that
were there and we went mental right
evolution just blew us up to the top of
the the kind of chain yeah so became the
Predators more earlier the hunted so to
speak through that as well you have to
have people who are willing to hunt and
kill it's just part of survival so
imagine in evolutionary terms
Psychopaths would once have been
important
you were a Roman Emperor you wanted
Psychopaths he would kill on your orders
without a problem without conscience it
wouldn't affect them you don't want
people falling apart because of murdered
people by the sake of here in the Mafia
you you want people who are going to be
hitmen don't
that's that without any care you know
we're actually like it's just going for
chopping so to some degree our society
has evolved to a point where we morally
do not need them we don't but still
right that's my idea anyway I'm not
saying that steep than the evidence but
that I can see it as being you know if
you look at DNA blueprints we have
people who are amazing givers don't we
you know we have the moderators of the
world people far better balanced again
listen I see it but what about the dark
ones you know there's got to be a
genetic mutation somewhere along the
line well that's funny what surprised me
is if you watch fighting and like us
alien things are done
you see professional fighters and you
would think that the Psychopaths would
probably gravitated up but most fighters
are some of the most compassionate
people like I've never looked at a
fighter in a post-fight interview before
when they've just finished a movie like
that they're very you know because
they're getting it all oh nice rules
little child Wow and that's another
thing so it's like we have killers in
the Army in the RAF and all of that we
need them but most of those will really
understand that this is a job and they
have no joy in having to do that is
about keeping us safe right so the
conscience is what allows them to do it
occasional Psychopaths won't be like
that like for example recently in
America we've seen that guy who's on his
knees begging for his life in the copper
blows of maleic you will see where a
psychopath has taken a job deliberately
- that's a policeman what did you say
that yeah it's really horrible footage
but I think the guy there's a writ
he had his hands above his head no he's
crawling he reaches back to his waist
and he's drunk they've had in that
situation you know you know the Baxter
is that way he had a gun in the room and
uh from tamiya knowledge he didn't have
a gun like the guy who was shot down
dead heat in the hotel yeah yeah the
kids pleading for as I see him please
don't shoot me I'm begging and the guide
says I'm gonna kill
so he blows him away from the reports
that I read of that and the guy was a
pest control guy and had a gun shoot
Birds all right I was showing his friend
this site a new feature on the gun
someone else in the hotel saw the gun in
the window and told the hotel and
obviously you're pretty stupid ones
we've come across what I'm saying is at
least that was maybe a bad example yeah
you do see people who do two jobs plus
oh my god of course it's like
Beautiful's you know of course you
create access have you had any
encounters with them in Georgia
yeah I'm really bad actually because I
actually I refused to work with sex
offenders does that make you bad is that
or is that just sort of I think that as
a professional it's really important to
challenge yourself and it's just the
area I have a black spot when it comes
down to working and listen the spectrum
of pedophiles is huge okay so one a
pedophile is not a child molester
a pedophile is somebody with a
predilection and attraction to children
because for example sexual massive
majority if Peter Faulkner acts so just
why am I talking about this because
obviously you deal with people and you I
deal with the victims of it and you have
a much bigger idea than I ever could
because I'm ignorant and I kind of want
to be ignorant you know because you just
want to think about no when you say like
look at society do you think that the
numbers of them in society would
probably scare people if we realized how
many are there just like a tiny little
sliver statistic in the UK is that by
the age of sixteen one in four girls
will have been sexually abused in one in
eight boys so one in six children will
be sexually abused by sixteen no it's
prolific so is that by someone whose you
don't want to come a prolific sex
offender but a reputed some new go throw
high volume of kids or is that by
separate no I wouldn't say that there
are obviously cases where we see
pedophile networks where they go through
a high volume of kids and one of the
things that people don't understand in
our society is just how wife it is and
obviously people don't want to think
about it because you know your children
not the most important things in your
life but
it happens all the time and children are
horribly abused in the UK and in other
countries and children are born into
situations where their lives are just
completely torn apart by that abuse
throughout yes it is really rife and we
see that throughout government we see
that throughout the media we see it
everywhere and this idea that pedophiles
and I will use the word child molester
because like I said a lot of people can
have predilections and attraction to
children but they know morally and there
would never act on it and they actually
seek chiefdom treatment in Germany when
the X factors on the adverts in between
our treatment programs for men and women
who feel attracted to children it's a
very open dialogue to try to prevent and
it works very well but it's very well in
the UK we hide it away or we have videos
online of pedophiles being confronted by
vigilantes and and when you think about
and I completely understand why they do
it yeah I do you know a retribution
wanted to protect children also some
individuals have themselves but abuse
they've got a lot of rage and anger the
police can't deal with all the amounts
of pedophiles out there the problem that
you do have of course is very often they
don't get leading to cases being
actually answered because of that a lot
of them get asked but and the other
thing if I'm really really honest is the
families of those individuals have their
lives completely broken so the person
who's in the video is one aspect of it
the ripples are huge record and then put
everything on YouTube for a reason
because it can ruin it yeah exactly
simple as that so I have complete
empathy and I would never judge somebody
who goes that one dude does that because
I do understand why but and I have
worked in situations where I've seen how
quickly pedophiles connect with kids you
know really really quickly tricky though
to make a relationship with a child like
I know I was at my little cousin's house
the other day and somehow our family
this is gonna be clipped up so badly
just like guy who keeps clipping up the
podcast all right
and sometimes and they just had a kid
and this kid was running around and was
friendly to absolutely everyone did I
hear anyone who doesn't know fear no
fear I never met before they don't know
somehow related but like yes they could
have run over anyway and that person
could do want to talk about that
spectrum when you asked me about do Iowa
sex offenders like it's live work we've
won and I couldn't continue to do it I
just couldn't continue to do it as a
female pedophile I mean I really
couldn't continue see so this is
something to ask you about them because
obviously we the general public just
think it's all men pretty much yeah what
so she was attractive areas what was she
wasn't when you say well she trusted the
kids like yes so she had been in a
network as a child or then had to become
part of the perpetrating that abuse
within that network so that was a really
difficult one for me to confront that
must be quite difficult for you because
you realize that person is a victim of
something which is then led to them and
it's slightly different but most people
who are sexually abused would find
reprehensible the idea of using children
and that's one of the problems when you
hear statistics like the majority of
individuals who sexually abused children
have been abused so you'll hear that
excuses right but also this idea that
sexually abused people might abuse
actually the reality is the majority the
mass majority of people who've been
sexually abused find sexual abuse
reprehensible would protect their
children beyond any measure and can
understand fully that they've been
abused and it's a terrible thing to do
the ones who go into it I often wonder
is that a power thing is it a sense way
you've had all your control and power
taken off you as a child so you imagine
well if I can make sense of it by saying
well I feel attracted to those children
and act in that way have I then got
control over what happens to me I don't
know that could be something that plays
into it but from my perspective we don't
understand aspect the spectrum very well
in our society so you have at this end
somebody who's attracted to children but
also to males or females so they can
have normal sexual relationships it can
still be attracted to a child but never
act on it right so that's the very very
end of that
right then you have here narcissistic
psychopathic serial killer child
molester that's how far it is and
somewhere in the gray area is the
average and when you talk to people
who've been molested and socially abused
very often people have this idea that it
would be this heinous horrific act that
is terrible but the confusing thing for
a lot of children is the pedophiles you
know the really friendly neighbor who
buys some treats and treats them like a
princess or a prince and is loving
towards them and forges a really strong
connection with them and then by the
time they start touching them well
actually this is just a game and it's
very difficult for a child to have
loving feelings in connection with this
other human being
so actually acknowledged they're a beast
so that then leads into that whole cycle
of shame where people feel they colluded
with abuse they didn't collude with
abuse their children can never collude
with abuse but you hear that narrative
playing out in the victims honestly all
the time you know when you are dealing
with people who are the victims and I'm
sure that in the most extreme
circumstances is it hard for you when
you go home and you know you put the
kettle on and to just not think about
everything you've been listening to all
day I really struggle in life with small
talk I always have done because all I do
is deal with really core central issues
of being human and so I suppose that's
how it affects me when I go home and
I've had the particularly harrowing
conversation with somebody or I've seen
the hardest pies when you see the harm
that people do to themselves when
they're complete victims and they just
don't deserve to hurt themselves in that
way you feel it but you also operate
constantly in a consistent belief of
hope like I spend my life just hopeful
so I get somebody who I have the
privilege of walking through their
territory with and going on that journey
with them and it's agony for them but
I'm looking down the line and I'm seeing
the potential and all I'm trying to do
is to almost put back in order the
humanity that they feel they've lost and
then add bits through compassion and
caring and loss you know I always say
that I don't care whether it's ethical
or not I feel a real sense of loss for
my clients you know because I want them
to be able to replicate what we have in
the room out there I want them to
understand that whilst there are people
out there who harm you there are also
people out there who want to heal you
and want to feel part of that journey
with you so when I go home I tend to
indelibly just feel like I'm privileged
I don't work in scenarios with a lot of
clients who pay for example I take money
to work with corporate so big companies
I do research for them and I charge them
a reasonable money I might do radio days
and I really enjoy that and that allows
me to continue to do the work that I do
with people who are not able to afford
therapy so because of that I get to work
in very dynamic scenarios with people
who've had really heroin journeys and
who have maybe not had the privilege
that I've had as a kid be brought by a
loving family and that constantly
reminds me I'm not ever an expert I'm
always learning and they're always
teaching me and I constantly go home
with that like a sense of I didn't know
that or I didn't feel that I've seen it
from a different perspective him when we
were talking earlier about grief and you
said that gives you another element
another area of your understanding the
other time that that's happened when I
had a two-year-old and a four-year-old
just literally for my husband and we
split up they run six miles every day
just done it forever and it was a real
therapy for me I mean it's my therapy
that physical release you know you
obviously exercise you know that real
physical chemical experience just a bit
just a little bit and and I was running
on a burst of stairs I'd never done that
and I went home and I was like
something's wrong so I rang my doctor
and it was like I need to come in see I
went in and saw him and they did tests
and my blood was really really low so I
was like six - I needed to go have a
blood transfusion and after that three
months I can't describe why I felt like
I felt so scared of everything I've
never thought scared like that in my
life I had really acute anxiety I would
say I was really depressed my parents
would come round this is ridiculous dad
we can't
they would comrades my house and I would
cry after market my kits of goods better
put that's better being fine you know
that old stiff upper lip the parrots of
come round I would cry for hours saying
you're going to die how am I going to
cope
that was my fixation and I did that for
about three months and then I had
another test it's holed up my iron
stores in my body we've just gone
I had no iron no ferritin and I started
having iron transfusions and physically
within a couple of weeks I was
absolutely great and there was a real
link between iron stores being low and
high anxiety funny because I've known
someone who has mood issues before and
and they have a massive iron deficiency
right and they very bad at treating it
in the UK so until you get to low 14
they won't even give you very sulphate
which is the tablets which is rubbish
really actually what you need is to be
transfused in America if you are under
40 you'll get a transfusion an infusion
they call an iron infusion it's half an
hour in you go and it completely
reenergized is your system and I had to
teach my GP about that before I was
referred and it was like a miracle you
know I've not been depressed or anxious
ever since but it taught me you have to
have like regular yeah all the time yeah
but it taught me how it felt to feel
like that I now want to work with people
who have depression your number
oh yeah and you know I didn't there was
a bit of me that was like right let's
just change your diet go for a run you
defined you know what I mean and I
realised there bloody warriors getting
out of bed and come in to see me let
alone and coping with day to day life
because that is I guess it's quite seem
like a trivial thing iron deficiency
yeah the worst thing is like forgetting
that were bad and all of that it's not
just that you're finding it hard it's
that it feels worse because everyone
else finds it easy
yeah that's such a good way of looking
at it [__] hell I'm really [__] yeah
it's bad enough I feel like [__]
everyone else is doing what I kind of do
I think that's a really good way of
looking at it that's exactly it's like
what if you're running a race and like
you're literally like crawling off the
finish line everyone's laughing you and
you're like it's bad enough I can't even
get off run and everyone else is making
this look terrible yeah totally agree
and I think that's a lot of that self
shame you know that feeling that you
should be going back to what we talked
about at the very beginning the idea
that life is meant to be this ABC linear
experience and when you're not on the
track in the way that everybody else is
you think there's something wrong with
you and also the impatience that we have
with mental illness like have massive we
all have a massive impatience with
mental illness the amount of
relationship counselling I've done with
people who've got a partner who's really
sick with depression and they're just
angry with them and I understand why
because you know living with somebody
who's depressed when you've got family
is quite limiting for you because you
almost become their Carragher and also
they can't motivate themselves to do
things that ordinarily you would do so
you kind of feel this resentment and
frustration and young people who feel
depressed as well you know when a
looking on social media and everybody
else's life just looks like shiny and
beautiful and you're looking at Kim
Kardashian you know who's made ludicrous
amounts of money because of a massive
ass you know and at the end of the day
they're saying what is it about my life
that means that I have not been able to
achieve and then they've already got
this chemical imbalance or this
emotional imbalance and it's a cooking
part of mental sadness do you know I
really you see someone famous just a
picture of poster picture nice I've got
[__] feel like [__] you know you
write and Davina McCall before Christmas
she's obviously just broken up with her
husband she put out a video dead brief
and it was just her saying I understand
that people are lonely and this is how
it feels I understand and all she did
was get absolute [__] online what do you
know about loneliness and again the
thing about loneliness mental illness Oh
cancer let's be honest any kind of
illness it doesn't it doesn't
discriminate it was a care whether
you're a successful wealthy individual
or somebody who's really poor it happens
so the the rhetoric online a lot of the
time is people can open themselves or
and then people attack them for that so
we have an impatience per se with things
don't go the right way you know what I
mean
well you get it online or the video
recently whales cry and unfortunately
well organ koala fella was given at that
and doing some stupid things we've shown
this dead body Thanks
and I was saying I get a lot of messages
of people who watch me and I ended up
crying cuz of these people who send us
all these messages in the field really
down in our field and I know us so much
support but you did I did see the odd
person just been like now you've crying
for views and all that life isn't it in
particular when you look at men of your
age the biggest killer suicide it's as
simple as that the biggest killer of
guys your age is suicide because people
don't talk about the feelings people
don't feel they've got permission base
to talk about the feelings and I hated
that video that he did by the way I know
he's lost loads of people following him
but he's probably got the biggest viewed
video ever as I knew that like guy with
the dead person hanging what I thought
was interesting though was that people
were berating him for laughing did you
notice that actually what's really
ironic is when I watched his reaction it
was not an unusual reaction to that kind
of scenario you know you don't know how
to react you react it's kind of laughing
and giggling being abused the mood
absolute - yeah it's a tool and the
thing is we often celebrate that kind of
completely social behavior because it
kind of behind you know we laugh it off
and as a group I imagine they were quite
affirmative about the video yeah and
there's sort of a mentality to that that
they couldn't no one there knew they
were doing something wrong I know it's
the untouchable side of it like they
think that they are the sudden reward
that they've had for the last god knows
how many years every time they do this
ignorant [__] why they get praised for
it all you all you do is you're in this
frame of mind of Oh radicals I can do
exactly my kids literally hate those
brothers they cannot bear them and
there's quite a lot of lads and girls
who talk about those individuals you've
probably done it here and you watches
those videos because it just validates
those feelings of like how are these
guys making so much money as he born the
Fall River I just have to say that one
said to do it just the dude I don't
actually think is a dude I don't think
it is he's a white middle class jock yes
that's not a yeah that's not cool
no it's not white people are lame man
okay
Middle America he's definitely no he
said a nice affable life he's been
affluent was his brother in what the
[__] is it no there's not his all double
the party got older brother in Breaking
Bad was his older brother and really you
see the little pillhead who's in Britain
by costly Breaking Bad everyone tells me
commentators shakin is ex-con comes in
handy for some stuff they about a public
though is that they're quite discerning
in the end I think that people could be
really really popular and do really
really well but in the end if you go too
far public are just like particularly
young people see this is I've worked a
lot of my life with younger people and I
really have enjoyed like the age groups
of like 15 to 25 particularly with 15 to
19 and then being one of the major areas
and I just see these kids know so much
more than people give them credit for
they see the world in ways and it's a
bit like when you look back at me 50
obviously thought I knew everything I'm
at 15 but at the same time I know I was
calculating and thinking and analyzing
and really thinking about the way that
the world works but not being
necessarily taken that seriously and
young people nowadays because of things
like YouTube in this kind of voice
they've got a voice of access that can
literally explore the way that they feel
is share and get validation and that
stuff about likes is really interesting
you know there's research out saying
that young people really react to the
liking you know when they get the likes
more likes it colors it is a little bit
of an addiction Authority well again
yeah and that's what a lot the research
is kind of indicating but actually one
of the things that they found is it's
dopamine that's getting released a
little hit of dopamine dopamine prison
yeah yeah but dopamine actually isn't
it's not an addictive thing it's just
like a little
nice on you know and and that's not a
bad thing but it's more about you know
young people are searching for
validation who isn't searching for dark
validation it is a lot like you've got
to that stage now where you're like I'm
okay um you know I always say to people
we're all gonna get old and ugly we're
all gonna die that's the real equalizer
so stop worrying about the things that
you think are so important like the face
the body all it is is from it to get you
from A to B you know it's a long time to
let go
yeah earlier the early you can get it
look er you are yeah the more we talk
buy the more they are going away from
that I think if anything in sort of I
don't know people who are like 50 and
over in their day because there was in
the social media and scrutiny over every
little picture and every no girl can
take a [__] picture without a filter
on these days I'm like people at surgery
like every girl is taking a picture on
and it's not their fault it's because
they feel so [__] screwed exactly and
sexualized and objectified that's the
truth of it as well I mean don't get me
wrong lots have gone by each other I
think girls probably look at each
other's pictures more than lads do lots
I just like though I agree you're not I
mean I agree I think there's a lot of
judgment towards girls bodies for start
the whole society is set up of a Western
cultural perspective about what a room
should look like and one it's completely
skewed and it's doing what you're
talking about it's making girls feel
that they have to right the world with
their bodies you know that as long as
they look a certain way and have that
picture like that exactly so they're
very aware of that
and the thing about marketing is that
you know they've done it really well
because marketers have created this I
mean this is all about let's chip away
your self-esteem
piece by piece as early as possible so
that in the end we can sell it back to
you product my product for the rest of
your life I don't think that's the key
yeah there's a lot of especially when we
talk about sort of the hero narrative
those sorts of things people just twist
that a little bit
again there's a very strong narrative of
dieting for a little while there's very
strong narrative of eating properly and
then when people overeat they go back to
the narrative everyone being overweight
it's basically now I think a lot of
people are quite cynical of I think a
lot of people were cynical of you crying
because they think you've got something
sell you think you've got your own
product so I've been trying to get a
t-shirt for 14 years me but the point is
it does teach people to be cynical
because there's it's we basically just
always flipping the story over and over
and over again yeah yeah push your own
whether you make money off it whether
you get social status there's some sort
of status or something whatever you get
off it there's always something behind
it and people are learning to
second-guess that look yeah but I mean
in human behavior to some degree there
is always a motive isn't that I don't
know when you ever watched friends years
ago where Phoebe was trying to be
altruistic you she just felt good about
it so she could be altruistic you know
but there is always a motivation and I
think it's sad though that when people
demonstrate real emotion for example
crying you'll be on a successful channel
you immediately want to kind of know
it's very successful you want to kind of
have people react with compassion as
opposed to yeah why are you doing that
because you want like so you want loads
of comments so you want to get loads of
views so you get more marketing that's
sad because what that says to every boy
who goes on and watches that is that's
what people think that I'm weak or I'm
stupid I'm doing it for a different
reason and then you can't just feel
anything yeah nothing for not like for
an or game yes you're not on a camera
yeah if those comments though are empty
in the first place or to some extent are
empty then do we have to wait those
comments in the same way because I think
would you get all of what we've all said
is given an awful lot of weight to the
social media or the comments that you
get on some video and actually I think
you address in the video which is it's
not really about the likes of the
comments or the the money you're going
to make off the video that if one person
sees it and they
feel like they can talk to someone
because of that that's probably is that
like way more important than exactly
that's exactly it yeah and you know it
as well as I do you know I get comments
about myself from people who literally
want to murder me
you know I've annoyed them that much you
could you break them down
psychologically and say I don't think
okay sometimes I just engaging them nice
them yeah okay or sometimes I'll correct
the spelling because I really don't like
it and he said they can't deal with me
in his spell you know you know it's a
psychopath the wrong way yeah I'm like
the thing is in the rule that you're in
usually on TV and I wouldn't have
thought that you would have come under
that that type of scrutiny and people
think I'm really annoying something
really yeah cause like I totally get
that suppose one of the things is as
well I get quite a lot of exposure
during a certain period of time wait
something will happen where I'll be in a
series and then they'll be three other
series I'm repeat from like three years
ago swimmy and like is nobody else
available for these shows and I also
personalities you know people like or
dislike you cause the reaction you can't
help it it's just the way it goes you
know
or is it quite mix women are actually
very rarely off women actually men and
younger men is that cause you're know
I'm thinking I'm trying to think why is
it that well the classic one is Oh
[__] sake
all she does is talk common sense that's
some insulin I literally I might [__]
hear telephone so it's like so obvious
and the art of why do is to take
something that's quite complex and
explain it in a way that's quite easy to
understand and I love how it yeah when
you explain something really hard and
then people go yeah I know you didn't
but I have to break it down pretty well
and that's one of the biggest myths that
I held for a long time in therapy was
that people understood what they were
thinking and doing and I've realized
over the years that a lot of the time
you actually need to give quite clear
and obvious advice and people are like
oh my god I've never thought about doing
it the this assumption that I used to
make that people thought in a way that I
thought was quite linear it's rubbish so
I
to learn a lot about the fact that
sometimes the glaringly obvious to me
it's the most disgusting of the human
being and to shine that light on there
and to help them move on and progressed
when I went through the hardest time of
my life what happened basically I was in
a really dark place someone had died in
the funnel and in generally I felt like
everything was just right and the whole
thing like everything that could go
wrong it was going and a close family
friend who was like and all that woman
just was who was very good at what she
calls ironing out your thoughts Nathan
and I just sitting have a cup over
though and I just sit and talk and talk
and this is why I've been telling people
you've got a talk at this point when you
hit that rock bottom and she wasn't
trained in any manner and she had a very
natural ability to help you map things
oh yeah and one side Sutton just who
heard meself what was in there and I
just let it all come out I'd walk out of
her house and I'd feel like clea yeah
all right this is helping actually
that's speaking your truth and having
some bear witness to it it's just such a
powerful experience I mean your mom's a
counselor so you've grown up with that
emotional literacy so in relationships
I'd imagine that the women that you've
had relationships with kind of see that
side if you've been quite literate I
think I think it's been interesting
because actually you're an emotionally
mature man yeah no I think a lot of I
think I've had really insight into like
also the like angst of cancer as well
and like how or a psychologist saw those
side of things because I imagine when
you lost your friend and I'm that
doesn't got to be difficult you can't
necessarily counsel people for that
subject for a little while after that or
you have to step away from that but
maybe you're too emotionally close to it
it's an interesting one because I'm
actually what I felt was that it was the
really empowering experience there's a
crack machines after though I imagine
that rusty quite difficult
kind of it's a strange one when my
husband left me well he I threw him out
it had an affair when my kids were too
close I've seen an article on Google
when I googled ooh yeah he did me a
favor I was oh yeah he did me and I'm
really a count really well with my
ex-husband he's got two new to was just
about so his second child and we're a
really dysfunctional functional family
you know it's as simple as that my
husband and him get really on really
well you know he pops him for a brew
this there's no animosity we just
weren't in the right relationship but
when I asked him to leave it was two
o'clock in the morning and I had to get
up the next day to go to work and I went
into work and I had a little clinic in
Oprah in manchester its massive College
and I saw the manager and just so needs
to check in with you to say that my
husband and me split up last night and
she was like go home and I was like I'm
not gonna go home I want to be here and
she's like I'm really not sure you
should be here after that and I said the
truth is I know that today in my room
every single young person that comes is
spite in a really really big battle you
know dealing with it if they can make it
to my room I'm gonna make it to my room
and I genuinely felt at the end of that
day it just did me so much good so when
Tom died actually what I felt was this
true connection to grief like it was
quite a beautiful connection it's
devastated and you know I know what you
mean by such beautiful because when
you're pouring your heart out behind
what you love so much
it's sort of teaches you a lot about
yourself of well this is how much I can
love some more and it sort of makes you
realize you're actually a pretty good
person yeah and the kraggen you know the
crying passes I don't think I've ever
cried like I cried and my boys will say
to me when Pam Dawber me you didn't
really cry very often it was like I did
but I cried contextually you know all at
Christmas
no I got with Graham miles sherry glass
out because the grandmas died and I
poured a glass of sherry don't know why
I don't even drink sherry but obviously
it's Christmas they should drink you
sure it's all right yeah half bottle of
its prey you know that little glass was
it great
go straight for a bottle of yeah yeah
but I poured it obviously half and every
but I just poured myself a glass and I
was starting to always feel it saying
well the kids had opened the presents
and I kind of said I'm just gonna toast
my friend and I literally just burst
into tears like honestly and yeah I'd
film like but the allowance and
permission of just letting it go I don't
know what the only way I can describe
that catharsis which is why anybody
who's listening who feels like you can't
show your emotions because you're gonna
get judged the catharsis when you just
let it go oh my god it's like taking the
deepest breath isn't it I used to have a
point of where I sort of knew it was
gonna come which is usually music yes
person then I know it's it's on the way
you set off in the car you just be
driving so anything about follow yeah
yeah in the UK often people say that
grief lasts you know as a certain period
of time and everyone expected you back
in the office and work in six weeks
after for a significant loss they
believed the process truely's about
seven years
you know that's all we had because I was
thinking seven years of me about seven
years and I remember when I lost my
close friend it was I remember thinking
to myself how the hell do people [__]
go away after all this [__] like I know
people who've lost people straight back
my work with a couple of weeks something
you haven't been on holiday me yeah yeah
how the [__] do people do it yeah cuz I
pretty much just went hit the destruct
button and every everything I could take
that was gonna make things worse I was
taken I know but the thing is you know I
often work people who like alcohol is a
really good example and people who drink
really heavily after some do what it
dies but alcohols ironically even though
it's a depressant yeah we know all that
it also black stuff out doesn't it all
cause one of those things that you drink
and if you drinking off of it it just
bloody disappears in sleep yourself so
that's where exactly yeah
yeah totally get that it's that thing of
I'm just gonna I remember when Pam died
you know
through a good future so as you slap
Ashlee vodka so you know and that's what
I do and my even though I did it
minimally because I kind of been quite a
analyst and uh you know writing you know
us first and also I would say to my
husband I'm gonna get busted and I'm
doing it for this reason because today I
don't want to feel as much you know and
he was very supportive in that and it
was never ridiculous but I would do it
and I knew and that's a really honest
thing for me lately you know I knew
dispensable not know and and have a
husband maybe who could be like oh you
keep an eye on me yeah it's one name to
make eggs on the NASA and then as long
as one day doesn't turn into fall for
exactly but like you said when you were
going through that it's this expectation
that well one it's a friend so big deal
you know that's one of the attitudes
that people have you know if you at work
and you work for a local authority or
you work for a private company you get
maybe if you're lucky one day off for a
funeral of a close relatives I mean
forget your friend your friends out at
the picture that might even a close
relative and you think yourself that's
how completely dysfunctional we are
about grief like one of the biggest
biggest experiences we go through in our
life none of us escape it every single
other person in this room is gonna get
that phone call one day and it's gonna
devastate us but even though we all go
through it
everyone's like oh let's just put it
into this box that make it as soon as
you where everybody could just function
and get on with it and then we wonder
why people are alcoholics or people are
holed up isolated in their own homes
overtaking whatever drug they're gonna
take or having promiscuous sex because
with her in and when we're hurt in
literally have to find something to make
it better and what makes it better is
what you said connection communication
bonding love but our society's fractured
now and what's happening is we're all
living in little boxes away from each
other
and that's the irony the answers there
and it's simple but for some reason our
society because of the capitalism and
they kinda in materialism and their I
have this you have that it stopped the
very thing that we need and when we
taught us at the beginning and again not
to go back to politics this lack of
tourists is not about that but that
every man
for himself mentality that's the worst
thing for us because you know how as you
sit down and you feel people around you
just with you it just it's something
magical it's something magical that
happens it's just this sense that we
were okay my sister came around at
Christmas because I had a really just a
shitty day and her and a husband turns
up and my sister's top now it's a woman
she's like you know she'll bring me and
say she's devastated because there's a
sink leaking you know it's that language
which is ace and she turned up and she
just came in gave me a hook sat down and
just talk to me for a couple of hours
and he did as well and he's not an
emotional guy her husband but they were
just that and you know it wasn't even
about what they said it was just that
made the effort they knocked on that
made me a cup of tea I think that that
was one thing that I realized when when
I lost that person was how many people
avoided us yeah because of the pain that
I was in yeah and people who I thought
would show up and be there such comments
to most people who I didn't think we're
going to be there Kim wow this teacher
taught me a [__] ton about life they
amaze me made us realize just who I
could count on and I couldn't count on
people say I'm afraid of saying the
wrong thing there was no wrong thing
there's no wrong thing just say stuff
people a lot of people are people are
selfish a lot of people and they don't
want to put themselves through having to
be in your presence I know that you're
in that pain because what that remains
them is that this pain is here and this
is real and it's gonna their life and
then be happy and live their thing none
that you're going through this yeah just
look after themselves it's really
painful though isn't it when you are the
person who has lost and instead of
having that community and continuity of
care from the people that you have in
your life they just desert you and
abandon you yeah even though you can see
like you're saying and thinking die even
though you can see the reasons behind it
feels that way yeah exactly I think
that's quite difficult because I think
also when people grieve sometimes I
think they there's a lot of blame as
lower anger and sometimes I can get
taken out on other people
well I've definitely seen friends go
through that when they've sort of lost I
think some people lost very close
relatives that sort of thing I've got
grandparents and everything that's the
same experience losing someone who's I
think it difficult
it's a really isolating process
definitely feel angry in that as well
yeah angers the second stage of grief so
it's a big part of it sometimes it lasts
a day sometimes it lasts years you know
Rogers become it's that sense yeah it's
our sense that it's unfair yeah why is
it happened and all of that but it's the
only reason for life if death you know
that's it it's the only thing that gives
map value if without death there is no
value of life you know
without knowing that something has the
potential to leave you you can't truly
manifest it's important so I kind of
look at destruction and decay which is
part of our experience is actually
something that's almost pregnant and
empty all in the same moment it's the
gestation of life that ends with death
and it's imperative and important that
we acknowledge and come to terms are
there but that we transfer what we've
learned like you're doing with your
friends and I can't do it my friend it's
about going god you know I was so
blessed I genuinely like I think about
her a million times a day i text the
phone still there are things that I know
that I'll and I know that you'll feel
exactly the same the conversations that
you no longer can have because you have
that relationship the laughs I had a
laugh that only she shared you know we
laughed in a certain way there were
looks that I didn't need to explain
anything there were things about our
relationship that are completely gone
forever
I can never recreate them with anybody
else but I hold that and think wow you
know I had like a long time well one of
the only things that give me comfort at
the time was wherever they are that's
where I'm going
that's exactly yeah yeah exactly it's a
really good philosophy and I think it
gives you great contrast is not an
excuse
of clubs you know I mean it's it's
welcome and everyone yes
no one's going to escape don't get away
I just thought that the logic that I had
to get from which you're quite similar
mean in that sense you have to find the
logic yeah might as well enjoy the rest
of me Tony that's that you know since my
best friend died we would talk endlessly
endlessly about what we were gonna do
you know and she was gonna buy so she'd
had quite a difficult time her husband
had died five years earlier she'd met a
new guy he was an amazing and could not
have loved her more at the end could not
have loved her more but five years
earlier her husband had died and she
spent like the next few years dealing
with her grief and we would talk a great
deal about it talking about what she was
gonna do when while she was gonna do
when and I would kind of do that so long
I'm gonna get a different house I'm
gonna move blah blah the minute she died
I was like I'm doing it I'm gonna do all
the things that I wasn't gonna do
because he was just talking and I put my
house up for sale I bought two more dogs
went away and traveled I've planned
things that I would never have planned
because I am NOT going to allow myself
to think that I have tomorrow using it a
make action don't don't sit ever and
this is the thing that I would say if I
had a message for anybody and definitely
if my own children don't think that you
have that time you know don't make plans
to make plans that never happen because
you're afraid of what happens if you try
and activate them like if you want it do
it if you want to try it try it it's
better to make a fool of yourself doing
something new and realize it's not for
you than to never do it you know do you
think that's actually that goes back to
what you talked about from being young
as well is it's very difficult as a
young person to when you hear a by she
think yeah yeah that's all what I'm good
something's taking to have to go through
it really do it yes so the more you can
engage them exactly knowledge in every
no yang experience because an old person
may be an old person can an elderly
person can tell you something that'll
send you on the path to go and do it
it's very rare an old person will say
something and then you won't do it do
you honey the likelihood is your touch
fire once or you'll do something like
that just to find out yeah you're a kid
or whatever yeah yeah you have to yeah
and that's partly I think the advice
that I give to a lot of people when they
email me and say what would you how can
I get into your career I might go and do
it like actually got yes really good
bullshitting themselves and like just
telling themselves oh well one day just
coming down the way and it's gonna come
to me no like you actually have to get
off your ass and do what he's probably a
really good time for that as well well
it's a reckoning isn't it miss you look
back nothing [__] me I'm 30
ya know but also the good thing about 30
years you're not quite at the point
where you're considered you're supposed
to be in your prime is no still
salvageable you're right at the
beginning no but yeah I just mean like
yeah I'm supposed to be me prime know
this supposed to be made me more
prominent and I'm just saying yeah I
think people are generally good at
telling themselves eventually things are
going to end up the way I want them to
without actually doing anything in the
job when someone dies it makes you pull
your head out your ass and will [__] me
this isn't forever some [__] right now
that's exactly and that's such a good
philosophy because also feeling the fear
that classic title of the book feeling
with fear and doin anyway you know
courage comes from fear you have to be
afraid before you get brave and brave
reinforces you know the whole context
that you can continue to do that yeah
formation it's not necessarily being
like a lot of the time you just describe
bad situations in a positive way that's
it I mean the reason I do that is the
two major concerns because the actual
neural pathways in your brain change
when you think positively so we can
clinically see how it impacts so I know
that when I make myself do that it does
it does it changes the neural pathways
and secondly I know that when I am nice
and positive all the people around me
are nice and positive or I impact on
their negativity and so my life feels
better like one of the things that I
look at to see whether I am like just
delusional cuz obviously I could believe
all this in people could be walking
around going what a dick you know what I
mean and that's fine and because you
know that can happen
but I look at my kids yeah and like last
night we sat it just sounds ridiculous
people be like how is she allowed to
have therapy with anybody but last night
you know my kids came to me like nine
o'clock and I was having a glass of wine
with my husband we don't usually drink
in the we were having a glass of wine
attention children yeah that's it just
me and my mom's file she bought me six
for Christmas I got through drinking
this anything else she bought me a
couple of browsers it didn't fit if you
really want to know you know why it's
basically we've got a motel four or five
years if the wrong size bra literally
every year I'm waiting for the one where
she hits it probability says by 93
she'll get it right
roughly yeah then they're back yeah
exactly you never know but but yeah so I
sitting down and Malad came downstairs
and my eldest is really emotional
literally young mrs. literate but my
eldest is just like I became a single
woman he was four so there's a lot of
like team stuff you know we were a team
I'm a younger [__] kind of came into
that but we were very very emotionally
aware and I've taught him a lot we
talked about everything no subjects off
the table my my lad knows that you could
talk about anything with all my it's 15
it could talk about porn day in sex
confides to me about everything like oh
keep secrets cause he does that is
allowed to you know but I trust him
implicitly in that way but he'll say to
me I don't get don't get people who were
depressed and his friends will tell them
he'll and he really wants to work around
that with them
no go I just kind of feel like pretty
happy all the time when things go wrong
I just kind of think well be one week
wonder I'll get over it which is
language that my mom taught me when I
was a kid you know one week one does
never feel like anything's gonna last
just it's one week wonder and he's got
that when we sat on a table last night
and had a glass of wine so it's probably
a bit more recessive and we just do this
stupid game it's a silly game and it's
like you know I'm thinking of an animal
it begins with the letter U right um my
eldest son just throat yeah exactly
I know I don't can't think of one as
well he throws words out and it's
hilarious and we sat there a unicorn
unicorn
car it's mythical but we start around
the table and we were doing that and it
was it was the
immersion in the most extraordinary
ordinariness of life and how bloody
brilliant is but also how being positive
and creating the atmosphere in my
household of positivity my husband's
hilarious I mean it's from saltburn in
Middlesbrough that's Middlesbrough e4
and grandpa saltburn he's the same he
takes everything and makes it funny
everything you know I'm not saying we're
always appropriate with our humour I
would hate to have dispatchers secretly
filming me but nonetheless that's the
way we are in our world and so
positivity yeah affirmative experience
and just like this belief that no matter
what I'll cope it's not even that I'm
not going to go through horrible times I
will my mum and dad are gonna die like
that'll be terrible when my cat's died
that was all poor you know her best
friend died that was terrible I've had
horrible things happen to me in my life
but the truth is I've always known that
I can get through it because I'm
hardwired to survive every single human
being is and in the darkest of moments I
just see that there is always that
flicker and it's not about being a blind
optimist
it's about being a very very real people
don't realize the strength have gotten
nature like my my dad recently as well
with his last and he's bloody useless
right it's nice up so [__] useless
he's had he's had a woman look after him
he's Hall entire house and he's had a
lot of women and he was like panicking
about being on his own and I'm like dad
man you're in fear I went you idiot
you're in your 50s it's the first time
in your life you've ever been on your
own you know look you are my [__] big
baby and you know it yes we fail them
he's being upset and he's being
miserable and all that but because his
ex last in all his finances and
basically do everything for him now he's
paying bills he's doing he's doing
everything he should have done the whole
time but he convinced himself I can't do
that I can tell Merriman's you know me
really he's lovely like a poem I've you
ever met my dad you know he's way
funnier than any Bill Murray that's so
funny guys that's not deliberately for
you Louise Barry he's been talking about
how on the road you are more likely to
be role models than people on TV these
days and that is a massive because
really as well with great power but you
know what though it is it's like you can
you know you can reach people and soothe
people and make people feel safe all
through the incident that blows my mind
because I mean I do these things online
like minute marbles for Instagram
erasure is like a minute to change your
life just a quick thing trying to get me
oh he's dead brief you know and I'll do
longer ones and then you'll get comments
and part of me is like I'd feel a little
bit narcissistic doing it like oh [__]
emotes are like gonna do that but then
at the same time you're like if it if it
just reaches somebody but they're
putting that into you you're not putting
that into yourself it's like Jimmy
Conrad Alamut always says take what you
do seriously not who you are yes and
they are asking you so they asking you
you than you or them do try you know
that's a really good point yeah yeah
welcome to the problem corner I've
already picked one out I don't even know
what to do oh sorry there's low there's
loads I returned but the boys wouldn't
be yes questions so this one comes from
we need a name what names you give this
male female female Gemma Jenna well
that's a good one Wow yeah yeah she's
got sort of like um she's got a very
American sort of posh girl name so nice
not too far off us right she's 20 year
old girl from the valleys I hey guys I
know how vain I must sound but here goes
I'm 20 years old and people think I'm
really attractive I'm pretty brunette I
have a small waist and I'm slim thick
that's what you like have a skinny
bodies but like she said it's good this
is what this can't be a real
we've got a rear wheel so don't get me
wrong I have lots I've lots of
insecurities like everyone else I just
want to know from a guy's opinion
Missouri people don't think I'm good
enough to date whenever I go out I have
lads following me around all night
trying to buy me drinks and I get
messaging on social media from people
who just want to have sex I've never
been him yeah all my friends are in love
so I feel like the odd one out basically
I think what she's saying is she dresses
proactively sometimes there's no
pictures now sadly for you but they feel
so it's clear that she doesn't have in
all the wrong places right I mean the
whole idea that you typing on I want to
say right yeah let's see I lit yeah but
my perspective value is just talking
about club scene guys who are drunk
following around you're not gonna find
it like also this idea that love is just
something that arrives because you're
beautiful is ridiculous and people think
that because we've got this population
now if a meet you say you've got tinder
you've got all the dating websites
everything feels so present that what
happens is people think it should just
happen finding love is quite miraculous
when you actually do it and it happens
and it's right it's an amazing yeah but
she needs to look elsewhere she needs to
kind of get brave why is she waiting for
the guys to make a move
why isn't she connecting with people on
baby social media that she's actually
interested in and making that kind of
expression and also just because guys
want sex doesn't mean that you have to
give it them so are you interested in as
well maybe someone who is into the same
before you because that's usually such a
good point the good star track and also
there is there is the possibility that
she might not be what she might be seven
point five who thinks she's a turn she
might be formed you know oh no a
psychopathic narcissist wouldn't be
asking you that because I
this most most not all more skills who
return have boyfriend's unfortunately so
really so maybe she's for sure do you do
things the other way around I found it I
like that actually so you're a 10
you know the boyfriend may be very clear
do you doesn't have a boyfriend but if
you are interested in Brian knew your
man slipping toes DMT more than happy
leave see you I have enough to himself
sorry to press someone you're just
looking through all the me lies yes nor
dick pics thank God yeah yeah that's
another she's on about the video I can
Paul that's a [__] the [__] and that
sounds good let's go for that okay
basically basically if I love uh
someone's get straight into it there's
no yeah yeah name man named Jonathan
Jonathan assume good basically I'm six
foot three and there is two girls from
my school Wow 653 yes and he's all done
yes cool would and one of them is known
for being kind of [__] because she
moved around schools yeah that's the
case if you change school you're a [__]
that's notorious tooks up yours yeah
clearly don't don't move school
standards school you [__] yeah and I
know some of my mates from the school
right and I know some weights from the
school she was at before and she shagged
two of his mates silly since she came
here
I don't give her really any thought
apart from this long email you've just
written but she got closer to me because
she's best mates with my ex that time
still mates with and she is now moving
she's moving to me and she's offered to
show her tits
both times and I never really wanted cuz
I never thought she was anything but now
I like her
a bit more but I don't want to date her
because I just so what he's basically
saying is there are also two other girls
that he's flirting with right
but he likes to sort your girl and he
doesn't want to go with that because he
thinks she's a [__]
go with the [__] girl me trust me on
this it's a really good idea Jonathan
Jonathan Jonathan there are no such
things as [__] if a woman wants to have
sex then a woman should have sex I've
made a mistake before where I mean I got
a girl when I was like 16 17 just
started college and she fancied me and I
showed that yeah and then I'm called a
couple of me mates and then in college
they told their mates who told them it's
and by the end of the day the whole
college knew I'd be in with her and she
felt like she was just mocked
straight away running fast in the
syphilis Hat so shut the [__] up when
you have sex with the girl all right
that's really good
saying that you not you not think as
well like he was just saying about you
know showing a boob spare times or
whatever that I can't get over how many
young people send videos and pictures of
themselves but then I really upset that
they show the mates like everybody
it's just what young people do isn't it
you get a picture of something you show
everybody another thing Lancers wait
until your mid-twenties until you say no
if if you are for a start if you're
getting attention you don't want all the
other girls knowing that you're getting
to keep everything to yourself right if
you if you are getting the girl
indiscreet keep that to yourself because
then other girls if they know you've
been with a skill are going to be put
off here for a star it must be really
tempting that I imagine when a girl says
to you I really want to show you my
boobs that you're like yeah they also
show if you're a teenage boys Eastern
schools yeah but she'll feel a lot of
pressure to act in that way like that's
the way it works these days you go on
porn channels you know what it's like
it's all about women wanting it women
being open to it you know
real impact on how you're having sex now
because like when I was like girls were
just like like clueless when I first saw
like only now when girls are having sex
they all they've watched porn and they
are well into that but there's a slight
problem there that we seem to think that
porn is a good way to have sex
oh no no dad Lee yeah do you think I
mean your watch your experience and I
just I find I mean like I've talked
twice before and I think that porn is
just the same story told the game in the
game which is that basically women are
desperate for it they love it to be as
aggressive and you know as really really
worth for and imposing as possible and
it's bollocks
you know women I mean women might like
it rough they might like lots of those
things but this idea that the woman is
this submissive character with the man
being that as you said actually earlier
aren't my hero that playing out the
masculine I I which let me tell you
every man I've ever met who's having sex
with a woman is grateful they are not
sitting there feeling like during it
many times you know what I'm saying
women women actually you know the big
truth here is that women are very
powerful in sex that's actually what
matters and so guys Matt in sex
you said in sex it sound like they're a
big part in sex but they are powerful
and we are we are Zeus life
well we can but also as far as sex goes
like a woman a woman will dictate
whether it happens or not yeah I mean
let's be honest though there's something
coercive yeah but yeah and they're in
good respectful relationships that's
what happens so this bollocks online
that women are all like these helpless
creatures who just want to have like
you'd be deep throated it's not true
and then you do you think do you do you
think her porn does perpetuate that so
for instance I had this conversation the
other night
my girlfriend over dinner we were saying
we would you know we were talking about
the morality of porn because we'd ever
see recently interviewed upon mobile and
we were talking about the morality of
maybe not challenging that or like not
you know talking with those sorts of
people what as if you maybe should have
pressurized them a bit more of whether
or not that was a good career well no I
would say I would say Terry I felt that
not guilty but sort of like it doesn't
validate what he does but some people
had said to us that company had that
porn mogul on there was a few comments
where people are disgusted in us for
allowing no that doesn't make sense
because the only way that we can form
opinions and understand things is to
listen and to open conversations I think
actually really important some people I
like do I think that porn is a great
thing
no because I don't think it's done in a
way that really promotes great sex yeah
we have a sickness in our culture around
sex we have people living in
relationships that are sexless because
they don't know how to have great sex
with each other
we have a real problem admitting what
our fantasies are to one another and
this a deep-seated shame where porn is
concerned often so it's kind of seen as
that's part of it and the fact it's like
an individual experience mostly used by
men mostly to masturbate on their own
not necessarily used in sex together so
to some degree the fact that it kind of
feels that exclusive relationship with
the screen and you and that it's kind of
seen as a bit north you're dirty that
kind of plays into so many myths and
really what we need to do is to be
having great sex
that's what we need to be doing but
we're not so we're going elsewhere you
know we're looking at so like people
will have a classic thing is guys tend
to have a particular interest in a
particular area right every man has it
gore - right exactly
it's yours so yeah well be quiet now
except do you want to know big booms
particularly okay what's our kind of
things and so you didn't have to grab it
no we're so insect like doggy position
is something that for you is that's what
it is
boos mine and she's so reading me right
now on top where you can hold it as a
guy exactly but often guys won't say
that Oh girls won't say it I mean I'm
actually putting it all out on the light
really this has been a very revealing
week on the two you can just say all the
time that's the thing yeah um and one of
the things that I think is really
important is that we start having so
when we talk about there is people stop
therapy is it valve or do I could mr.
smight therapy is about like honesty
yeah and when people are having sex
together they're revealed you know you
like it
you're as vulnerable as you're gonna be
and yet for some reason you don't
transfer that as well as some people
still have a wall up during sex so like
when I've had sex with certain girls
this like like no but they don't relax
and that's where pong comes in again but
for most tell you if a woman is
performing his sex she will not have an
orgasm yeah no I mean that that's funny
like in Euro there where you were like
let me shoot yeah she's true well no not
every times it's quite hard for a woman
to do that all the time and anybody who
thinks that they're giving a woman an
orgasm every time is because she's
faking it and it's not as simple as that
my cousins are timers exactly that's
actually very true and and also you know
you don't have to have that but what I'm
saying is performance this stuff on
screen it's like you have to act a
certain way and yes role plays brilliant
it's fantasy based and of course you
should but what I'm saying is we're not
getting to the stage where people are
actually having those connected physical
experiences because they're not telling
the truth do you think there's an
element of because what was quite
interesting was our mind hunters hunters
recently on Netflix which is about how
the CIA started to map out yeah violin
yeah but most of them were sexually as
they called them sexual deviants I don't
know if they still use that term
what's a deviant normally every normal
could be loads of people then oh yeah
but you talking sexual deviant more like
when it's not legal
alright wait sorry Bailey aware it's a
particular predilection that we kind of
is on the edge of God that brings back
memories I think maybe in Britain's
taboos where there was one guy who he
killed the girl and then have sex with
the body and then took pictures as well
yeah he posed her yeah he dated his
daughter that was terrible [__] me up
that link to be honest oh yeah yeah yeah
necrophilia that poor police officer I
know he was amazing that fun was amazing
I know I know but that's the class
that's that is something that's a
predilection for certain people is very
very rare very very rare fortunately do
you think the kind of shaming of people
who watch porn I don't think you should
show him anybody I was going to sort of
forces some people on the ground or sort
of I don't think porns bad right I don't
think it's bad I think the way is given
sewers is telling a narrative that's
untrue I'm not saying that I know what
to do with that industry I don't know
what to do that I don't think that a man
should to feel embarrassed or a woman
should feel embarrassed if you want to
use it in sex together that's play
that's fine I always talk about sex
being I don't play it's really really
important that people enjoy it but I do
think that there is a narrative within
it which says a woman is supposed to
enjoy whatever I give her thank you very
much and it's about as far from the
truth in great sex as it goes and like
one of the areas I love working in is
with sex therapy I love it because I
know that it only takes telling the
truth and sharing fantasies and actually
engaging in trying out new things that
make sense and just being open that's
what makes fantastic sex but when you're
young and this is the thing about young
people yeah and I've talked to my kids
about it quite a lot because obviously
I've got 15 year old son at some point
he's gonna have sex it's as simple as
that
yeah hopefully is gonna have sex
whatever you whatever II choose whatever
exactly yeah I mean here
bitesize yeah but he undoubtedly knows
from my point of view that I live we'll
watch porn at some time I've said to him
you know be selective be discerning
about the poem that you watch because it
actually changes the way you think about
bodies limb bones that you're right so
let's think about it ideally go for the
softest of where it actually feels like
there might be a consent in relationship
there and also when you go on dates with
girls like don't feel a pressure to have
sex but also if you do and you want to
make sure it's good make sure that you
are pleasuring her and he/she is
pleasuring you because don't register
time kiss don't but you know what kids
right genuine with the pressure they
feel on and girls particularly to go
ahead and do it and boys because they
feel like they've got to get it out the
system because that's going to happen
like I want my boys to both remember
their first time not as the hideous
affair and people have got time to think
about that but this kind of portrayal
online is something that just some
degree has the potential my main problem
with porn I don't think is good about it
is when I first started watching I when
I first started looking it it's about
12:30 yeah like that it took me a hell
of a lot less like maybe a picture of a
girls I was there that's right
whereas within about some cats a lot
people used to do it women in Nickerson
bras that was sort of five five years
later and then it has to be hardcore
half an hour
and it has to be quite sort of
aggressive yeah and that's very classic
and that's also all right people have
aggressive sex yeah of course it is of
course is but what he's saying that is
important to know drugs in a sense well
it's exactly like toaster you've got a
gross more you've got to take more to
get that high and that's exactly the
same exactly that's exactly it so yeah I
don't have an issue with it I just think
it could be done better I don't have an
issue with anything liberated about sex
because I think sex is great and what
would you say to this guy who wants to
doesn't want to see this girl's breasts
but also has two other girls he doesn't
want to get known for dating easy girls
so I think you
what the [__] your eyes yeah give her a
[__] chance because an open-minded
woman's a very good thing absolutely and
also you know what the guys are having
sex with though the guys are just as
culpable so stop seeing it as a female
thing and see it as a natural and
liberated you okay if I was to have sex
with a girl and I was given a choice of
a girl who'd had a hundred men are zero
I'd go for the hundred so Billy Connolly
says he ever seen Billy Connolly when he
says about he's talking about the air
not that have any issue with them with
Islamic faith that's all I don't and but
you know that the extremity is the ISIS
situation and they're being promised
virgins and he said that's not heaven
for me we did say the way that Isis is
tell them that when they get to heaven
it's gonna be full of gay men yeah that
again oh they won't like that I'm sure
some of them would like is it like
because some of them will be pressing
buttons a lot sooner one in thirty of
you will be gay take a look around your
den one of yous gonna be going
absolutely statistic is my penis broken
I'm sorry can we click the phone comes
from I love the fact that guys are
writing in and actually imagining that
you are gonna be able to explain that to
them about my years of training as a
consultant there with your broken
penises no no I've had a friend who did
get this I went and did know years ago
Pitt Peter Cook like pgl holidays for
kids yeah like the like waitress it's a
song recording on one of these covers
all right well pgl trip yeah why don't
do this I went I went away and it was
for kids holidays and I went that was
crazy the staff they were insane it was
like how they were allowed to look at
kids I'm sure it's better now back in
the day in France it was like people
were going to recover from something so
on two things happen that were
terrifying one this lad broke his penis
and it was everywhere blood was
everywhere and you had to have medical
attention straight away and then
not like if this was not oh it's a girl
just to throw in a girl story as well
this girl I knew she was dancing on a
chair and she fell and it was this
handle was there and it's back of the
seat broken and it went straight inside
it was terrible sexual injuries in a
hole or it went straight in and it saw
all the way out of it it would do so can
you imagine the statistical possibility
of that I mean so you said at the time
that's amazing because something when
you get on top of woman it takes a
couple of seconds to get yourself ready
you know what I mean but I thought you
are you gonna tell this story from now
on when someone's well I mean it's a
cheap and good you wanna know what else
jonno another story na oh yeah let's
miss is really bad so a lot that I know
was playing football with he had his dog
wasn't playing football with people who
play with this dog anyway put his jacket
on the top of this a kind of football
thing and was being stupid afterwards
climbed upon it to grab it like climbed
physically upon it there jumps off and
as he did he slipped and one of the net
Hawks
went straight through his bollocks and
ripped them that actually happen eed to
be more careful up there
come eat what's happened to his dick
yeah so we are actually playing fight to
talk about this we are with all of our
experience we've all heard about barking
Dixit some profound jaws of the famous
one is even I haven't got one in that me
what really annoys me is when when women
get on top and they just don't take it
you know let me just be too hard well
yeah oh if you're that confident with
your dick just make sure you're you know
on point right quite literally what's up
guys love the podcast so earlier this
year I was with this girl that got
sexual pull of a son it was cool the
only problem was when it was signed
about the condom when I struck
what it did I panicked and it went stuff
that happens not normally it happened
another time so she went on the pill and
I hit it raw everything went fine
everything went fine we were not we are
not together anymore and I will be
involved with other women eventually
here we go
most girls will make me wear a condom
this makes me very nervous what do I do
any advice PS who do you think watching
porn is part of the problem well
actually that doesn't actually appear to
be guys that is a problem because people
start we know that so and when you're
watching porn you're utilizing exactly
but also if he really wants to work on
not going soft when that happens he
needs to practice pushing one on what is
using porn if he's gonna use it for a
positive purpose so just kinda it will
also take that away and I was I've tried
to get a little bit away from the porn
and ideally just sit on the bed and
masturbate using a condom because that
will again that will stop that fear
process what it's going to have is a
fair process because it interferes with
the moment and it's not unusual for men
to lose a hard-on at that stage so just
to get his confidence back up in that
way and also you know ask the girl if
you're in a situation ask it to put it
on with a mouth you know things like
that that continue the stimulation
socially do you think a lot of girls
will be able to put a condom on with
their mouth like that no but the thing
is obviously you're gonna have you're
gonna have the condom at the top yeah
and so I get the I get the logistics of
that I just think why are you having sex
with somebody that you can't ask to do
something if you lectured him yes I
don't know how well no but you'd say you
can say to somebody no I mean would you
mind um for me in a way that's like sexy
because I fight it spike I think it's
totally normal to say to a guy or a girl
say to a guy regret to say to a girl
it's condoms through a bit on sexy there
bill sex how can we make them a little
bit more sexy can you just like do it
for me and like do it with your mouth or
when I was sort of 60 and 15 when I
started when you were totally legal in
your 60 when I was 16 and even when I
was like sort of 17 18
around a woman I mean it's almost like I
would be region and then I'd shut the
bedroom door behind us and the nerves
and there was a few aims where yeah yeah
it didn't go according to plan like but
once IV I don't know what happened but
it was almost like just once I stopped
caring that was it but it was that
getting to that point where you you have
to let go of the worry of what she's
gonna think
yeah they if it doesn't happen right
there and then because one thing that
men do when they caught the sleepers
they get hot it is so if you just say
you know can we just wait until I'm
ready yeah and more Skills to be pretty
understanding of that three o'clock in
the morning you know it's not the worst
thing that we'll do it wait a woman up
and be like actually are you ready
exactly so maybe no but maybe that's
actually not the worst thing in the
world because some lads just yeah I
think men how so much pressure and I was
equally when the younger they have so
much price for sex really relies on a
man in a massive way I mean if you are
not large and rock ready and not that
the Cooper sound as well the floor play
there doesn't it you know feeling like
you can ask for that I feel like you can
get what turns you on and also about
fantasy because again you know if you
are experiencing that kind of level of
fantasy that you really into you will
just get harder it's as simple as that
and it's the same with a woman you know
again this seems to be quite a lot of
shame about discussing sex . and talking
about what you want but when you do
you're essentially creating equation for
a great relationship physically yeah all
the kind of things that you release not
try not really want the day before will
have a full 24 hours of just no one and
before because i'm the new sort of for
some men it's like they'll come to
quickly they get hard but they come to
quickly so they want before but other
men who can't stay hard it's because
you've been wandering the night before
saw find the balance well yeah and also
i'm like safe for plays always great
because then she'll make Europe more
relaxed ashes exactly and I mean
turn for her you know that's one of the
things that guys don't understand that
you know women really do need more
stimulation a lot of the time and
actually by doing that you'll have a
miles about her experience and he hasn't
got a broken dick yeah it's not broken
it's just it's just it's a bit shy and
so yeah it's losing momentum
yes losing momentum momentum get her to
be involved and likes their practice and
if he's watching a lot of porn try to
get a little bit away from that what
will be the issue is like it's an
extreme thing so yeah you've gone from
watching a girl who's probably taken
except one so yeah it's just yeah a
regular don't surveys with young girls
under 15 16 year old girls yeah and
they've actually said that they feel the
pressure to have anal sex that's a big
question
Wow now when I was growing up you know
anal sex is like something they heard of
in the mountains there was like it never
happened
village of strange anal people yeah and
nowadays it's just like I saw with my
first girlfriend I remember she was like
tight like terrified of getting pregnant
yeah so she was like just put up me off
yeah I was like are you sure yeah it
didn't fit no I was like I was that was
what she wasn't pregnant because anal
sex was just part of conversation yeah
yeah it's changed so much but then again
that puts pressure on lots of girls you
don't want to do it you know lots of gay
men don't know how Saints anal sex is a
large mothership gay men don't have anal
sex because it's not always pleasurable
I mean it is if that's what you're into
is great if that's what you're into
bought you do have to kind of recognize
particularly the younger generation that
everyone don't think it's like you know
the superheroes don't exist either just
cuz you see on screen doesn't make it
actually real I mean a bit as a proto
there brings home you mean clean
conscience yeah you're absolutely right
there will be porn about that produced
EP reporters weirdly enough I'm sure
they do
oh we enough
the girl next door is called or
basically I'm good friends of the
neighbor next door as are my parents so
they came around the other night to
celebrate Christmas they brought the
daughter who I vaguely knew but we got
on and started talking and later that
night outside we were left in the lounge
and things got a little heated oh let's
say and she basically said she likes me
wow we really got heated
don't say I like you however however I'm
talking to someone at the minute that
speaking them speaking to them what does
that even mean no one's carry things on
with my neighbor if she's a 10 out of 10
I think what would ya asking what would
you to do and if we do start to crack on
how would we go about it as it isn't
something that's easy to hide away from
our parents parents have working hours
yeah I mean my first girlfriend live
around the corner so I was in yeah I
don't kind of get what his quandary is
like I know he's speaking cuz I've got
this thing my niece is like spooned over
16 and she's like speaking to guy and I
was like what was speaking and she was
like well yeah well he she's like yeah
she's like well speaking is we're not
actually officially going out with each
other but we're not speaking to other
people so I was like I just like I
preferred the old day to just like you
want to go out with me and then you like
off with each other that was the way it
was as men and you're like officially an
item straight away for like three weeks
but that one that he said there isn't
the problem is it because he fancies his
neighbor she's a 10 out of 10 they're
getting together she likes him and the
only issues and parents the parents will
be chuffed because the parents would be
like nice one we don't you know I on
them you get on with you get on with you
it's gonna be great think about all the
fun with our oceans could have barely
countywide animus they only come of
course is just you're close to a degree
enjoy it but then be respectful in front
of her dad that's miles that's right if
you can win our dad all that then you've
all right that's the thing be respectful
yeah and also don't rush it no just let
your yeah yeah good luck view of the
girl down gently
yeah I don't coaster don't go
don't ghosts grow a pair that's what I
think yeah grow a pair have the
conversation or even just sort of write
some sort of message eyes I don't like
you anymore I've met my neighbor you
know just about you're an A in she's a
10 yeah definitely don't tell her like
that maybe he's talking about the girl
at the very beginning who thinks that
she's a 10
yeah maybe that's it we've probably
heard crossover going on yeah
many many crossovers people vengefully
emailing that's been a good one it's
really nice thank you very much for
coming on absolutely
we usually end it on on a question go
how would you like to be remembered I'd
like to be remembered as somebody who
had a quirky sense of humor and didn't
hurt too many people along the way I
made really good cakes cakes make oh my
god I like making carrot cake cheese
cake chocolate cake all of them they're
not like bakelite
the light the taste isn't as good as
baked off cakes but they look pretty
crap but the really taste of our dress
isn't really that bad as well if your
mum can bake it's really good all the
mates think it's cool they really don't
care yeah they just they're just a bit
I'm just mom well thanks for coming
thanks for having them hope you enjoyed
it you lot and we'll put your links for
everything that you're getting the food
in the description so cheers everyone
say